All
right.
So, how the debate is going to go, uh,
the title of the debate is, "Did Jesus
claim to be God?" We're going to have
opening statements. We're going to have
rebuttals. We're going to have counter
rebuttals. There will be clocks for the
speakers to see. You guys won't see
them. And then, uh, after all of that,
we're going to move the the table to the
middle and we're going to do open
dialogue. And then after that, we're
going to do some Q&A just like we've
been doing the past couple nights. Ray
Rock with the microphone. Do not grab
his microphone, okay? He's real serious
about it. And so this is gonna we're
gonna go for I'd say at least two hours
tonight, okay? It's gonna be a fun
night. And um we're going to have both
gentlemen give opening statements, uh 20
minute openings, okay? And it's going to
be fun. So uh let me introduce our
speakers for the night, our debaters for
the night.
First up, who will be arguing the
affirmative? Ladies and gentlemen, warm
round of applause for David Wood.
Oh yeah.
The podium is right here.
David Wood, ladies and gentlemen.
All right. And all the way from
London, England. Um, I've I've had a
blast getting to know this brother for
the past couple days. It's been super
fun. And he's probably going to hate me
for saying this, but he actually joined
us on his birthday weekend.
All right.
Without any further ado, ladies and
gentlemen, warm round of applause for
Alex O'. Connor.
All right. Oh, yeah. We're good. Let's
You ready? Tell us when you're ready so
we can start the clock. I'm ready now.
Oh, you started. Okay. Well,
good evening. Good evening. What a
beautiful audience.
You're all breathtaking. This is how you
uh charm a crowd in America, son.
like to thank uh Rustlan for arranging
this conference and this debates, one of
many awesome debates taking place in
2025, pitting heroes against
villains. I won't say who the villain is
in this debate. I'll let all you lovely
Christians judge that for
yourselves. Based entirely on our
accents. And speaking of British
accents, I'd like to thank Alex for
finally showing
up. You got to give me some wiggle room
on time,
Rosean. Or you can all quit cheering for
Alex. All right. Well, I'd like to thank
Alex for finally showing up. I was a
month and a half late, but he finally
showed
up. I'm teasing, by the way. Uh people
have no clue how dangerous debatecon is
actually with the lineup they had and
the number uh and the volume of death
threats against uh multiple speakers. So
uh plus he lives in what is rapidly
becoming the Sharia compliant hell hole
of the universe. So good to take
precautions. We don't want to lose Alex.
By the way, are you guys starting to
miss Jesus over there in the UK? Seems
like you should be missing Jesus by now.
Speaking of Jesus, did Jesus claim to be
God?
Yes. Yes, he did. And I'm sure uh many
of you have some verses going through
your heads right
now. However, I'm convinced that the
primary way Jesus claimed to be God and
that his followers claimed he's God uh
gets overlooked by most Christians and
non-Christians because we've lost touch
with first century Jewish culture and we
just tend to uh not notice things.
Let me give you an example of what I'm
talking
about. Here's a quote from Daniel
Boyerin in his book, The Jewish Gospels,
the story of Jesus Christ. The story of
the Jewish Christ. He says, "Most, if
not all, of the ideas and practices of
the Jesus movement of the first century
and the beginning of the second century
and even later can be safely understood
as part of the ideas and practices that
we understand to be the Judaism of the
period.
The ideas of trinity and incarnation or
certainly the germs of those ideas were
already present among Jewish believers
well before Jesus came on the scene to
incarnate in himself as it were those
theological notions and take up his
messianic calling. So the ideas were
there paving the way for Jesus who
embodied them. Now, who's Daniel Boyerin
to say that Christian ideas like the
trinity and the incarnation were already
present in some form in first century
Judaism? Is he a Christian apologist?
No, he's uh he's a scholar of rabbitic
Judaism. He's a Talmud scholar. He
points out that a lot of the beliefs we
now think of as distinctively Christian
actually weren't. The earliest Christian
church was embedded in first century
Jewish culture. But as Christianity
spread, it became dominated by gentile
Christians who tended to lose touch with
the Jewish framework. And something was
happening within Judaism as well. As
Jewish orthodoxy was forming in the
second century, the rabbis tended to
weed out certain ideas that had once
been familiar in Judaism, but which had
been adopted by Christians. The rabbis
wanted to clearly distinguish Judaism
from Christianity and some of the ideas
that were present in first century
Judaism were soon deemed
heretical. So Christians lost touch with
the Jewish framework of early
Christianity and Jews abandoned some of
the Jewish ideas that became part of
Christianity. And the result is that
today it's easy for us to miss a few
things when we're reading the Bible.
claims that would have been uh
understood by listeners at the time
might not be understood by us. Here in
my opening statement, I'm going to
briefly discuss the forgotten Jewish
idea that's most relevant for
understanding how Jesus claimed to be
God. And then I'll show how this
forgotten Jewish idea illuminates
various passages in the New
Testament. Some of you are familiar with
the early Jewish belief in the two
powers in heaven. Ellen Seagull, the
Jewish scholar, drew attention to this
in his 1977 book, Two Powers in Heaven.
And lots of people, especially
Christians, have been interested in the
topic ever since. Here's the idea in a
nutshell. The Old Testament is very
clear that there's one true
God. But there are numerous passages in
the Old Testament where we see two
divine figures. I'll give a few quick
examples. There are tons of these.
Sometimes God seems to be in two
different places doing two different
things. Common example is the story of
Sodom and
Gomorrah. The Lord appears to Abraham
and tells him that he's going down to
Sodom and Gomorrah to see firsthand how
bad the people are. So he goes down to
Sodom and Gomorrah. And what happens?
Genesis 19:24. Then the Lord rained on
Sodom and Gomorrah, sulfur and fire from
the Lord out of heaven. The Lord on
earth rained down fire from
the from the Lord out of heaven. This
thing reboot every couple minutes. Uh it
sounds like there are two lords here.
Watch what happens in Zechariah 2. Pay
attention or you'll miss it. Come Zion,
escape you who live in daughter Babylon.
For this is what the Lord Almighty says.
Who's speaking? The Lord Almighty. And
he says, "After the glorious one has
sent me, the Lord was sent by the
glorious one, against the nations that
have plundered you. For whoever touches
you touches the apple of his eye, I will
surely raise my hand against them so
that their slaves will plunder them.
Then you will know that the Lord
Almighty has sent me." The Lord Almighty
was sent by the Lord
Almighty. Next paragraph. Shout and be
glad, daughter Zion, for I am coming and
I will live among you, declares the Lord
Yahweh. Many nations will be joined with
the Lord in that day and will become my
people. I will live among you and you
will know that the Lord Almighty has
sent me to
you. The Lord Yahweh will live among
them and they will know that the Lord
was sent by the Lord Almighty.
So Yahweh rains down fire from Yahweh.
Yahweh is sent by Yahweh. Plenty of
passages like
these. Then we got a mysterious figure
called the angel of the Lord. Whenever
you think uh whatever you think of when
you think about angels, just get rid of
that. Uh the angel of the Lord is no
ordinary angel because this angel is
somehow the Lord. Angel just means
messenger in Hebrew. It can refer to a
human messenger, a spirit messenger, or
in this case the Lord himself. Look at
Judges
6. The angel of the Lord came and sat
down to talk to
Gideon. The angel of the Lord appeared
to Gideon. Then it switches to the Lord
turned to
him. The Lord answered. Then it goes
back to the angel of the Lord. Then when
Gideon realized that it was the angel of
the Lord, he exclaimed, "Alas, sovereign
Lord, I have seen the angel of the Lord
face to face." But the Lord said to him,
"Peace, do not be afraid. You are not
going to die. If you see the Lord in all
his glory, you're dead. But if you see
the angel of the Lord, who is somehow
the Lord, you might survive." One more
example of this. Here's Jacob blessing
Joseph in Genesis 48. Then he blessed
Joseph and said, "May the God before
whom my fathers Abraham and Isaac walked
faithfully, the God who has been my
shepherd all my life to this day, the
angel who has delivered me from all
harm, may he bless these boys." He
singular. So the God, the God and the
angel are all referring to the same
being. The angel is God, but the angel
is the messenger of God. This is all
over the place in the Old Testament from
Genesis all the way to the prophets. We
just don't pay attention to it when
we're reading. Uh but there were ancient
Jews who paid very close attention to
passages like these. And they realized
that something very, very strange is
going on. There's one God, but there
were two powers, two authorities in
heaven.
If you put all of the passages together,
it seems like there's God you can't be
around because his presence would
destroy you and God you can be around
somehow. There's God you can't be around
and God you can be around. The God you
can't be around is distinct from the God
you can be around. They interact with
each other. One sends the other and yet
they're both
God. This was all very, very confusing
to first century Jews.
If there's one God, why are there two
powers in heaven? Why are there two
powers who both act like God? They tried
to deal with this problem in a number of
ways, but mainly they were confused. And
then Jesus came along and he says in
effect, you know those two powers that
you've been reading about in the
scriptures, you know those two powers
that you're so confused by? I can tell
you about those two powers because I'm
one of
them. That's the primary way Jesus
claims to be God. It's the primary way
his followers claim that he's God. It's
a primary way uh it's primary issue that
enrages his
opponents. But did Jesus really claim to
be one of the two powers in heaven?
Since Jesus is a highly controversial
figure and since there's a skeptic in
our midst, I would suggest that if we
want to know what someone like Jesus is
claiming about himself, we can look at
six things. We can look at what Jesus
says and what Jesus does, what he says
and does as they relate to our topic. We
can look at what his friends say and
what his friends do. Here I mean what
they say and do in reaction to him. And
we can look at what his enemies say and
what his enemies do. Again, in reaction
to him. So, what Jesus says, what Jesus
does, what his friends say, what his
friends do, what his enemies say, what
his enemies do. I would put all of that
together and say that's our evidence
that we need to account for, and that
will give us the best indication of what
Jesus was claiming about himself. I
don't have a ton of time left, so we'll
consider a few things Jesus says and
does and a few things his friends say
and do. Along the way, we'll see um the
reactions of some of his enemies, and
maybe I'll add a few more uh examples in
the
rebuttals. What does Jesus say? Jesus
claims to be one of the two powers in
heaven in multiple ways. I'll give you
three. The most familiar is the father
son language he uses. Jesus claims to be
the son of God. Now someone can be a son
of God in various ways in the Bible.
Blessed are the peacemakers for they
shall be called sons of God. But Jesus
claims to be the son of God in a unique
divine sense. One example, Matthew
11:27. All things have been handed over
to me by my father. And no one knows the
son except the father. And no one knows
the father except the son. And anyone to
whom the son chooses to reveal him. All
things were handed over to the son by
the father. No one knows the son except
the father. Obviously the people around
jesus knew him in some sense but they
didn't really know him. Only the father
really knows him. And no one knows the
father except the son and anyone to whom
the son chooses to reveal him. No one
can know the father unless the son
chooses to reveal him. This should sound
somewhat similar to the old testament
idea that there's god you can't be
around and god you can be around. Two
powers, father and son. Jesus is the
son. Mark 12. While Jesus was teaching
in the temple courts, he asked why did
the teachers of the law say that the
Messiah is the son of David? David
himself speaking by the Holy Spirit
declared, "The Lord said to my Lord, sit
at my right hand until I put your
enemies under your feet." David himself
calls him Lord. How then can he be his
son? Whose So whose son is the Messiah?
He's the son of David. But David calls
the Messiah his Lord. How many lords do
we have here?
The Lord said to my Lord, according to
Jesus, the second Lord here, the Lord of
King David is the Messiah. So, we've got
two powers in heaven, and Jesus is one
of them. On a side note, if you're a
Christian and you're wondering why we're
talking about two powers instead of
three, where's the Holy Spirit? Uh, he's
there,
but but we're focusing on how Jesus
claimed to be God, and that's connected
to the two powers in heaven. Mark 14
again the high priest asked him are you
the Christ the son of the blessed and
Jesus said I am and you will see the son
of man seated at the right hand of power
and coming with the clouds of heaven and
the high priest tore his garments and
said what further witnesses do we need
you have heard his blasphemy what is
your decision and they all condemned him
as deserving death what do the what do
the enemies say this is
blasphemy what do they do tear their
garments That's what they do when
they're outraged about blasphemy and
condemn him as deserving death. Why do
they react like that? The son of man,
that's Jesus' favorite title for
himself, who will be seated at the right
hand of power. So, there's the power,
which sounds like God, and there's the
son of man coming with the clouds of
heaven. How many powers in heaven? I see
two here. And Jesus claims to be one of
them. So, who's gle who is Jesus
claiming to be at his Jewish trial? He's
claiming to be the son of man prophesied
in Daniel 7:13-14. Daniel says, "In my
vision at night I looked, and there
before me was one like a son of man,
coming with the clouds of heaven. He
approached the ancient of days and was
led into his presence. He was given
authority, glory, and sovereign power.
All nations and peoples of every
language worshiped him. His dominion is
an everlasting dominion that will not
pass away, and his kingdom is one that
will never be destroyed."
So, there's the ancient of days, God.
But there's also the son of man who will
be worshiped by all nations, whose
dominion is
everlasting, and who comes with the
clouds. In the Old Testament, Yahweh is
the one who rides the clouds. Humans
don't. Angels don't. Isaiah 19. See, the
Lord rides on a swift cloud. Psalm 104,
the Lord wraps himself in light as with
a garment. He stretches out the heavens
like a tent and lays the beams of his
upper chambers on the waters. He makes
the clouds his chariot and rides on the
wings of the wind. So God comes with the
clouds. So we've got the ancient of days
who sounds like God. And we've got the
son of man coming with the clouds of
heaven who sounds like God. Two powers
in heaven. And Jesus claims to be one of
them.
Jesus claims to be one of the two powers
in heaven multiple times, multiple ways,
in multiple sources. Jesus says a lot
more than that. But what does Jesus
do? Jesus judges the world. In the Old
Testament, David says, "The Lord abides
forever. He has established his throne
for judgment, and he will judge the
world in righteousness." Who's the judge
here? Yahweh.
But in Matthew 25, Jesus declares, "But
when the Son of
Man comes in his glory, and all the
angels with him, then he will sit on his
glorious throne. All the nations will be
gathered before him, and he will
separate them from one another as the
shepherd separates the sheep from the
goats." Jesus goes on to say that he
will admit certain people into heaven
and cast others into hell. Why is Jesus
the final judge? He tells us in John 5,
"For the Father judges no one but has
given all judgment to the Son that all
may honor the Son just as they honor the
Father." Whoever does not honor the Son
does not honor the Father who sent him.
If you don't honor God, you can be
around. You don't honor God, you can't
be around. Jesus also raises the dead at
the
resurrection. According to the Old
Testament, Yahweh is the one who raises
the dead. 1st Samuel 2:6, the Lord kills
and makes alive. He brings down to shol
and raises up. But Jesus says he's the
one who raises the dead at the
resurrection. John 5, truly truly I say
to you, an hour is coming and now is
when the dead will hear the voice of the
son of God, and those who hear will
live. For just as the father has life in
himself, even so he gave to the son also
to have life in himself. And he gave him
authority to execute judgment because he
is the son of man.
Do not marvel at this, for an hour is
coming in which all who are in the tombs
will hear his voice and will come forth.
Those who did the good deeds to a
resurrection of life, those who
committed the evil deeds to a
resurrection of
judgment. So Jesus claims by what he
says and what he does that he's one of
these two powers in heaven. And that
means he's claiming to be
God. And his friends got the message.
How do his friends react? What do the
early Christians say? In Philippians 2,
Paul quotes an early Christian song or
poem or creed about Jesus. Goes like
this. In your relationships with one
another, have the same mindset as Christ
Jesus, who being in very nature God, did
not consider equality with God something
to be used to his own advantage. Rather,
he made himself nothing by taking the
very nature of a servant, being made in
human
likeness. And being found in appearance
as a man, he humbled himself by becoming
obedient to death, even death on a
cross. Therefore, God exalted him to the
highest place and gave him the name that
is above every name, that at the name of
Jesus, every knee should bow in heaven
and on earth and under the earth, and
every tongue acknowledged that Jesus
Christ is Lord to the glory of God the
Father. What's the name that is above
every
name? Yahweh. And at the name of And at
the name of Jesus, every knee should bow
and every tongue acknowledge that Jesus
Christ is Lord. This is a reference to
Isaiah 45. In verse 18, Yahweh says,"I
am the Lord and there is no other." Then
in verse 23, he says,"Before me, every
knee will bow. By me, every tongue will
swear." The early Christians said,
"That's
Jesus." So Jesus was in very nature God.
Then he humbled himself by becoming
obedient to death. Then God exalted him.
How many powers do you see
here? Two. And Jesus is one of them.
Paul quotes that. and obviously agrees
with it. But look at how Paul describes
the two powers. For us, there is one
God, the Father, from whom are all
things and for whom we exist, and one
Lord, Jesus Christ, through whom are all
things and through whom we exist. There
is one God, the Father. You see, Jesus
can't be God. It's only one
God. Well, keep reading. And one Lord,
Jesus Christ. Does that mean that Jesus
is Lord, but the Father isn't?
All Paul does here is take two titles
for God and says,"I'll call the father
God and Jesus
Lord." Two powers and Jesus is one of
them. What about John 1? In the
beginning was the word and the word was
with God and the word was God. He was in
the beginning with God. All things were
made through him and without him was not
anything made that was made. There's God
and there's the word but the word was
God. How many powers? Two. And Jesus is
one of them. If you really want a fun
verse later in the same chapter, try
John 1:18. No one has ever seen God. The
only God who is at the father's side, he
has made him
known. Sounds like two powers. It's what
the early Christians say among other
things. What do they do wrapping up?
They worship him. They pray to him. They
sing hymns to and about him. They
baptize in his name. They compose
liturgy and doxologies to honor and
praise him. In other words, they give
Jesus the full array of religious
honors. What could convince a bunch of
first century Jews that a carpenter from
Nazareth was one of the two powers in
heaven? Probably the same thing that
convinced his enemies that he was guilty
of
blasphemy. Would have to be something
big. Either really big claims of Jesus
or a really big
misunderstanding. We'll uh see which
option Alex goes with.
All right, that is David Wood's opening
statement and Alex is going to take the
podium for his 20 minute opening
statement. David went over 1 minute and
14 seconds.
So, we will give Alex a grace period of
1 minute and 14 seconds.
Can everybody hear me through here?
Yes, David didn't factor in the
clapping. I always factor in clapping
into the timing of my speeches. Good
evening, ladies and gentlemen.
[Music]
Thank you. Or as we say in England,
assalamu
aalaykum. I I I must apologize for the
previous debate fiasco. David's right
that most people don't know what
happened. A lot of accusations thrown my
way. But I suppose that is the essence
of our debate this evening. People
thinking they know a thing or two about
a person without hearing it from their
own mouth. To which effect I was
thinking about how to approach this
given that I didn't know which approach
David was going to take. I woke up this
morning in this fine resort
um opposite Legoland, which means that
there's a a roller coaster just outside
of my room. And being a bit jet-lagged,
I woke up quite late to the most
peaceful of noises, that is the sound of
children screaming for their
lives. Hearing the sound of innocent
children screaming for their lives, of
course, reminded me to read the Old
Testament.
And I wanted to
begin with a
verse. That was too
easy. I factored that into my time as
well. I want to begin with a verse from
the Old Testament which might become
relevant momentarily and that is well a
psalm not in its entirety but Psalm 82.
Psalm 82 is a curious psalm because it
opens by saying that God presides in the
great assembly. He renders judgment
among the gods. Elohim that is
definitely the word for gods. This seems
to be an indication that God is talking
about or the psalmist is talking about
the so-called divine council which also
shows up in Job for example. Later in
the psalm he says, "I said you are gods.
You are all sons of the most high." The
psalmist is referring to beings here who
are definitively not Yahweh. but calling
them gods, which is kind of interesting.
I'm not trying to make a point out of
that. Jesus is going to do that for me.
As we turn to what I think is the most
important christoologgical gospel of the
four, which is of course John's gospel.
Many people think that I just dismiss
John's gospel because it's written too
late or something. It is of course the
least historically reliable of the
gospels, but I'm willing to just treat
it as if it's historically reliable for
the purposes of this debate and see what
Jesus actually says about himself. The
question we're interested in in here is
the relationship that Jesus has to his
father. David has been speaking about
the two powers in heaven heresy and
saying that Jesus's relationship to the
father is the kind of relationship that
people who believed in these this two
powers was talking about. Well, let's
investigate that in Jesus's own words.
There is one place in the gospels where
Jesus is directly accused of claiming to
be God. Do you know where it is? It's in
John chapter 10. In John chapter 10, his
Jewish opponents come to him and say,
"If you're the Messiah, tell us
plainly." And Jesus responds by saying,
"I and the Father are one." I'm told by
Christians, this is a direct
christoologgical claim. Who can claim to
be identical to the father except for
someone who is
God? And there was no confusion about
this. The Jewish opponents picked up
stones to stone him to death for making
this claim. Now, how does how does Jesus
respond? Does he agree with them or does
he correct them? He
says in response to the Jews, "Is it not
written in your law I have said you are
gods?" Quoting, as you'll probably
realize, the psalm that I just quoted
and explained briefly a moment ago. So
directly asked about his
christoologgical status, Jesus decides
to quote a psalm which is explicitly
talking about beings who are not in fact
Yahweh and yet are called gods. Why
would he pick that psalm if the message
he wanted to convey was that he is in
fact in some sense God that is identical
to Yahweh? Jesus continues, "If he
called them gods, why wouldn't he call
me God, the one who the father has sent
and set aside? So why then do you accuse
me of blasphemy because I said I am
God's son?" Like in the divine counsel,
you shall be called gods. That is sons
of the most high. So it's a
misunderstanding.
Jesus immediately afterwards clarifies
further and
says believe the works that is the works
of my father through me that you may
know and understand that the father is
in me and I am in the father. Another
pretty intense christoologgical claim.
What does it mean? Let's turn to the
most important christoologgical chapter
in John's gospel which is of course
chapter 17. Jesus is praying first for
his disciples then for all of his
believers. Remember in John chapter 10
so far Jesus has made two claims. I and
the father are one and I am in the
father and the father is in me.
Addressing the relationship that he has
to his father which David thinks is the
two powers in heaven. What does Jesus
say in his own words? John 17 20
onwards. My prayer is not for them alone
the disciples. I pray also for those who
believe in me through their message that
is all of you. That all of them may be
one. Hen hen, the same Greek word used
in John 10. Father, just as you are in
me and I am in you, may they also be in
us. This is crucial. This is pivotal.
When Jesus is asked to clarify his
christoologgical status, what is his
relationship to the father? He says,
"I'm in the father and the father's in
me." He then later prays that all of us
will one day be in God in the same way.
Just as cathos in the Greek, which
doesn't just mean as, it means in the
same way as. Just as if this is supposed
to indicate that Jesus is claiming to be
identical to Yahweh, what does that make
the rest of us? And how I'm interested
in knowing is David going to interpret
these verses where Jesus is specifically
asked to clarify his relationship to the
father and tells us that he is only in
relationship with him in such a way that
everybody else can be in relationship
with them too. The same thing is true of
another important quote from John's
gospel which is when Philillip asks
Jesus to show him the father. What does
Jesus say? Anyone who has seen me has
seen the father. Another intense
christoologgical
claim. He then follows up by saying how
can you say show us the father? Don't
you believe that I am in the father and
the father is in me? The words I say to
you I do not speak on my own authority.
rather it is the father living in me who
is doing his work. So again Jesus
clarifies his relationship to the father
this time saying that he doesn't speak
on his own authority. But there's more.
In the same chapter this time, chapter
14, just a few verses later, he says to
those same disciples who he's just told,
I that if you've seen me, you've seen
the father because the father is in me
and I'm in the father. He speaks of a
future day past his crucifixion and says
on that day, verse 20, on that day you
will realize that I am in my father and
you are in me and I am in you. So to
recap, Jesus is directly asked to
clarify his relationship and his
christologology to the father. And he
says that I'm in the father and the
father's in me. And guess what? You'll
all be one with us too one day. If this
is a claim to be Yahweh, then well,
lucky us, I
suppose. Now, it's difficult to know
where to take this because of course
there is a third really important
christoologgical claim in John's gospel
which is in chapter 8. I think it might
be relevant to talking about the
understanding of ancient Jews and we'll
see where this goes. Of course,
famously in chapter
8, Jesus is talking about eternal life.
And his Jewish opponents say to him,
they challenge him and say, "Well, our
father Abraham, he died. Are you saying
you're greater than him?" And Jesus
replies, "If I glorify myself, I glorify
my glory means nothing. Your father
Abraham rejoiced at the thought of
seeing my day and he was glad." They
say, "What you? You're not even 50 years
old and Abraham has seen you." And he
says, "Truly I tell you, before Abraham
was, I
am." Why is that important? Two reasons.
Firstly, he seems to claim pre-existence
to Abraham, which is pretty significant.
But also, this invocation of the word I
am in Greek, ego am, which many people
think is a call back to the divine uh
name of God given to Moses in Exodus
3:14. In Exodus 3, Moses asks God, "Who
shall I tell them has sent me?" And God
says Asha, which means I am that I am. I
am who I am. So go and tell them that I
am has sent you. It's interesting. But
of course, the New Testament is not
written in Hebrew. It's written in
Greek. And it's well known that the
authors of the New Testament were using
a Greek translation of the Old Testament
called the
Septuagent. This is something that was
pointed out by J.R. Daniel Kirk. So I'm
indebted to him for this.
If you read the Septuagent that the New
Testament writers were using and we have
very good evidence to suggest that John
as well is using the Septuagent. How is
this verse rendered? Exodus 3. God says
to Moses, "Ego Amy,
hon." And it's used commonly like this
in John chapter nine. The blind man is
healed by Jesus. He runs into town. They
say, "Is this not the man who was born
blind?" And he says, "Ego Amy, it's me."
When Jesus is asked by the woman at the
well, the woman at the well says, "I'm
expecting the Messiah to come." Jesus
says, "I am he." Ego Amy. Once
again, that is how it is often used. So
in the Greek Septuagent, we have I am
hon. Go and tell them that Hon has sent
you. In the Greek Septuagent, in other
words, the abbreviation of the divine
name is not ego Amy. It's Hon. And it's
ego Amy that Jesus says. And in fact,
Jesus says the words ego Amy six times
in chapter 8 of John's gospel. And yet,
this is the only time it seems to annoy
anybody. Why is that? Well, maybe
because it's got more to do with the
fact that Jesus seems to be claiming
eternality. But supposing for a moment
that this really were uh an invocation
of the divine name, I'm just willing to
grant it. Let's say okay he was meaning
to evoke this imagery of Exodus 3 by
saying I am here we have to understand
as David is quite right to point out the
cultural context of early Judaism and
there is a tradition in early Jewish
texts or at least texts of around the
contemporary time to the gospels of
endowing beings who are not Yahweh with
Yahweh's name and thereby enabling them
to exert his authority as his
representative on earth. David has
already talked about the angel of
Yahweh. And there is the suggestion that
the angel of
Yahweh is
Jesus. That doesn't seem to make much
sense to me. For a start, if you turn to
Hebrews chapter 1, the very first verse
says, "In the past, God spoke to our
ancestors through the prophets at many
times and in various ways, but in these
last days, he has spoken to us by his
son." in these last days. If Jesus is
the angel of the Lord way back in
Exodus, the story of the Exodus, why is
it that Hebrews says he's only spoken to
us through the sun in the last few days?
Likewise, in Acts chapter 6, Steven is
recounting a history of the Jews. And in
it, he says that an angel spoke to Moses
through the burning bush, not Jesus, but
a messenger of Yahweh. It's a little bit
strange, but suppose we just accept that
the angel of Yahweh is a bit difficult
to unpack. Augustine himself, by the
way, said that the angel is correctly
termed an angel if we consider him
himself. But equally correct, he is
termed the Lord because God dwells in
him. What does that mean? I think it's
an invocation of the divine name. This
is most elucidated for me when we turn
to non-scriptural Jewish writings of
around the same period. For example, in
well, actually in third Enoch, Metatron
is called the little
Yahweh, invoking the divine name. And in
fact, to the extent that the Talmude
warns Jews not to confuse Metatron with
Yahweh, because that seems to be the
implication of what he's saying. But he
is in fact just invoking the name. The
most important example of this for me is
the apocalypse of Abraham written around
the same time as the
Gospels, a Jewish text which tells the
story of Abraham who hears the voice of
God and he's terrified and he hits the
ground and God he hears the voice of God
speaking to an
angel and he speaks to an angel saying,
"Go Yahweh," that's the name of the
angel of the same name. Through the
mediation of my ineffable name,
consecrate this man for me and
strengthen him against his trembling.
Through the mediation of my divine name,
which he's given to the angel Yahawel,
Yahel, by the way, Yah and
L., it is a substitute for the ineffable
name of Yahweh. The writing of which is
forbidden, and that's why he's called
Yahawel. And in fact, at one point, God
is himself addressed as Yahawel. In this
text, Abraham is told by this angel
Yahawel, "Stand up, Abraham. Go without
fear. Be right glad and rejoice for I am
with you. For eternal honor has been
prepared for you by the eternal one. I
have appointed to be with you and the
generation prepared for you. So the
angel invoking the divine name by the
way says to Abraham,
"Rejoice for I'm preparing for you
essentially redemption and it will come
from your generation." And by the way,
when Yahawel when Abraham finally stands
up, one of the descriptions of Yahel's
appearance is that his hair is white
like snow. Where have we heard that
before?
But interesting, isn't it? Let's think
about the context of John 8:58. A lot of
people forget that we're talking about
Abraham. Why are we talking about
Abraham? Why is it here that Jesus says,
"Before Abraham was, I am." Well, if I'm
right that he is just identifying
himself and the thing that's important
is the Abraham claim. Could this stem
from a similar tradition? This is what
Andrew Perryman has suggested recently
that when he says, I mean, this whole
thing gets kicked off because Jesus
says, "Abraham rejoiced to see my
day." Well, hold on a second. And in the
apocalypse of Abraham, the angel Yahawel
says to Abraham, "Rejoice for from your
generation will will come one who will,
you know, redeem
you." So is it possible that a common
tradition has Jesus referring to the
fact that Abraham rejoice to see his day
because he was promised this redemption
from the beginning of time? It's
possible. It's a suggestion. I think
it's quite an interesting
one, but it is a little strange that
Jesus claims to be pre-existent. He uses
the present tense, I am. It's worth
bearing in mind that the Bible sometimes
does this when it is talking about plans
that are pre-ordained from the beginning
of time. For example, in Revelation 13,
we hear about the lamb who was slain
from the creation of the
world. It's talking about Jesus there.
Jesus wasn't crucified at the beginning
of the world, but it talks about it
almost in the like in the present tense
or at least as if it happened there and
then. Why? Because the plan for this
redemption through the lamb was set in
stone from the beginning of time. So it
talks about it as if it's in the present
tense. Similarly, famously in the book
of Jeremiah, God says to the prophet
Jeremiah, "Before I formed you in your
mother's womb, I knew you." He also
says, "Before you were born, I
consecrated you as a prophet." How can
you consecrate someone as a prophet who
doesn't exist yet? That means that
Jeremiah must be pre-existent, right? He
must be No, not necessarily. It just
means that God had this plan. It's a
poetic way of saying that God already
knew what was going to happen and had
planned this from the beginning of time.
So, putting all of this together, there
is an interesting interpretation of
Jesus saying that Abraham rejoices here
my day. And the Jews not understanding
him, not getting it, he says, "Look,
before Abraham was, I am. I am the
fulfillment that was promised to Abraham
and was from the beginning of time and
here I am now. Of course, this is all
exesus and it's a little uh sort of
spotty. But the most important question
is probably about blasphemy. David
mentioned blasphemy in a different
context earlier. Why is it that they
pick up stones to to stone him to death?
Because of course, if I'm looking for a
sound exesus of correctly interpreting
the words of Jesus, I turn to his Jewish
opponents who consistently throughout
the gospels are always understanding him
correctly. No, the theme of the gospels,
especially John's gospel, is how
comprehensively the Jews misunderstand
what Jesus is saying. When he says, "I
and the father are one." They say, "Ah,
you're claiming to be God." And he said,
"No, no, you're not getting me." When he
says that he forgives sins, and they
say, "Ah, you know, who can forgive sins
but God alone?" He says, "You're not
understanding me." And hopefully we can
get into that actually. And here, of
course, when they say,
"Ah, we're going to stone you." We're
not told exactly what blasphemy they
think he's
committed. Do we now just think that
they got it right? That they correctly
understood what he was saying? I'm not
so sure. Especially considering
that if you look in Acts, again, I've
already mentioned Acts 6. This is
Steven. Steven is telling the story of
the Jews to the Jewish authorities who
he's been brought before on charges of
blasphemy. He's eventually stoned to
death. Why? Because he has a vision. In
Acts 7, filled with the Holy Spirit, he
gazed into heaven and saw the glory of
God and Jesus standing at the right hand
of God. Notice God, not the father.
Look, he said, I see the heavens opened
and the son of man standing at the right
hand of God. At this, the Jews cover
their ears, run up to him, and stone him
to death. Notice the similarity, by the
way, between this depiction, looking up
and seeing the Son of Man sat at the
right hand of God, or stood at the right
hand of God in this case, and the claim
that Jesus makes in his trial. It's
quite interesting.
Steven is stoned to death for this. Did
Steven claim that Jesus was God here?
Did Steven claim that he was God here?
Sometimes Christians act as if the only
way to commit blasphemy is to claim to
be God. That is simply not the case. In
fact, in Acts chapter 6, we're told that
Steven has been fraudulently accused of
blasphemy. They're making up charges
against him. Here are the charges that
they that they throw at him to bring him
before the court for blasphemy. This man
never stops saying things against this
holy place and the law. For we'd heard
we've heard him say that Jesus of
Nazareth will destroy this place and
change the customs Moses has handed on
to
us. Ladies and gentlemen, if changing
the customs that Moses has handed on to
us is enough to get somebody convicted
of blasphemy, I'm not sure we should
read too deeply into the accusations of
blasphemy against
Jesus. There's so much to say. I've got
everything I want to respond to. We have
rebuttal periods. So if I haven't
responded to everything David has said,
hopefully I'll get the opportunity then.
But this idea of the divine name being
invested into people and him having and
them having the authority of God without
being Yahweh themselves is I think the
important ticket here. One slightly less
biblical example is a story recorded by
Josephus which came to mind when David
was speaking. When Alexander the Great
approaches Jerusalem in an attempt to
conquer it, the crisis is
averted. When a priest whose merit bears
the tetragrammaton, Yahweh, bears the
name of God, comes out. And what does
Alexander do? He bows down before the
priest. Was Alexander bowing down before
the priest or was he bowing down to the
divine name that was in him. When every
knee will bow to Jesus, what is the
context? Jesus has been given the name
that is above all other
names. Given it. This is a common theme.
And so David's right that we need to
understand what how the early Jews were
interpreting the the various verses that
we were reading. But I don't think it
lends too nicely to his interpretation.
Jesus is constantly talking as if he's
not speaking with his own
authority. He's doing this all the time.
The most instructive example for me is
in John 12:44 when Jesus cries out,
"Whoever believes in me believes not in
me, but in the one who sent me." That's
if you read the NRSV. The NIV adds in
the word only. "Whoever believes in me
believes not in me only, but in the one
who sent me." That word simply isn't in
the Greek. It's a little bit strange. I
want to talk more about that. I want to
talk about authority and where it comes
from. I want to talk about the forgiving
of sins. I want to talk about worship
for sure. And whichever roads we
whichever one of those roads we go down
is essentially up to David Wood, but I'm
ready for any of them. So, we'll see
what comes up. Thank you for
[Applause]
listening. All
right. So, that is Alex O'Connor's
20-minute opening. So, David is going to
go back up to the podium. He is going to
do a 12minute rebuttal round. All right.
Thank you, Alex. In my opening
statement, I showed that in the first
century, there was an interesting
discussion within Judaism uh about the
two powers in heaven. They had various
ways of dealing with this. Um and we can
see why when we read passages like
Genesis 22, the story of Abraham and
Isaac. But the Lord uh but the angel of
the Lord called out to him from heaven.
Abraham, Abraham. Here I am, he
replied. Uh wait, no. Then God said,
"Take your son, your only son, whom you
love, Isaac, and go to the region of
Mariah. Sacrifice him there as a burnt
offering on the mountain, on a mountain,
I will show you." So this is God saying
to Abraham, "Take your
son." Verse 11, "But the angel of the
Lord called out to him from heaven."
Abraham, Abraham, is when he uh starts
to do it. "Here I am," he replied. "Do
not lay a hand on the boy," he said. "Do
not do anything to him. Now that I know,
now I know that you fear God because you
have not withheld from me your son, your
only son. So this is the angel of the
Lord saying, you haven't withheld from
me your only
son. And it was God who answer who
ordered Abraham to do this. Um so we
have we have situations like this and I
argue that Jesus enters the discussion
uh when they're confused about the two
powers in heaven and claims to be one of
them. And so there we looked at what
Jesus says, what Jesus does, what his
friends say, what his friends do, uh
what his enemies say, and what his
enemies do. Uh Alex uh seems to suggest
that the there could be some sort of uh
angel or something like this or even a
person who's in who's endowed with this
kind of divine authority. Uh you got
problems with this even uh even here in
uh Genesis. Uh so look at what this
said. Then the Lord Genesis 33. Then the
Lord said to Moses, "Leave this place,
you and the people you brought up out of
Egypt, and go up to the land I promised
on oath to Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob,
saying, I will give it to your
descendants. I will send an angel before
you, and drive out the Canaanites,
Amorites, Hittites, Perizzites, Hisites,
Jebusites. Go up to the land flowing
with milk and honey, but I will not go
with you because you are stiff necked
people, and I might destroy you on the
way." Who is accompanying them and
guiding them? Well, the angel of the
Lord. But here he says, "I'm not going
with you this time." So, this is the
Lord speaking. It's not the angel of the
Lord and you say, "Oh, this is the
Lord." This is the Lord speaking. This
is the Lord speaking. Says, "I'm not
going up with you now." When it was the
angel of the Lord who was accompanying
them. So, these are the sorts of things
you have. And people tried to figure out
how to deal with this. And they came up
again with all sorts of ways. And Jesus
entered the picture and claimed to be
one of the two powers in
heaven. So, what Jesus says, we went
through three examples of Jesus claiming
to be one of the two powers. He's the
divine son of the father. He's the lord
of king David. And he's the son of man
coming with the clouds of heaven. And we
saw how people reacted to him claiming
to be the son of man coming with the
clouds of
heaven. Um in
response, Alex was quoting uh he quoted
Psalm 82 and then Jesus uh using this
using this passage. So let's go ahead
and take a look at this. So they accuse
Jesus of claiming to be God.
And Jesus answered them, "Is it not
written in your law I have said you are
gods? If he called them gods to whom the
word of God came and scripture cannot be
set aside, what about the one whom the
father set apart as his very own and
sent into the world?" So Jesus is sent
into the world according to this
passage. Why then do you accuse me of
blasphemy because I said I am God's son?
Uh this is not and I have no idea how
you would ever read the gospel of John
like this, let alone anything else Jesus
said. This is not Jesus saying what
you're misunderstanding. I'm just a
regular
dude. I again, if you if this were the
only verse in there, maybe you because
if if given the rest of what we read in
the Gospel of John and the rest of the
Gospels, Jesus is not claiming to be a
regular
guy. He's using a legal technicality
here that they should be aware of.
They're saying, "Hey, here's what you're
claiming. You're claiming to be a son of
God. This means you're claiming to be
equal to God and so on, and therefore,
uh, this is blasphemy."
And Jesus response is, "Well, that
really well in the Psalms." In the
Psalms, God calls people
Elohim. Therefore, you can't just say
calling someone some divine title is
blasphemous and deserves a death
sentence. You have to show that it's
some that the title is not from God,
that it's not true, that it's false.
Have you done that? No. Okay. You can't
kill me. You can't just say there's a
claim and therefore we will kill you
over it. So, that's a legal
technicality. Again, if you're if you're
somehow reading this as, "See, Jesus is
just claiming to be a regular
guy."
Wow. All right. So, we have John
17:5. And now, Father, glorify me in
your presence with the glory I had with
you before the world began. Why? Alex
quoted John 17 to show that Jesus is uh
just claiming some some uh regular
relationship that we can all have with
God or something along those lines. What
does Jesus say in the same chapter that
Alex is quoting? And now, Father,
glorify me in your presence with the
glory I had with you before the world
began. That sounds like Jesus is
claiming to have glory with the Father
before the world began. Doesn't sound
like he's claiming to be a regular guy.
Doesn't sound like he's saying, "Oh, you
guys are just misunderstanding
everything I said. It's just one big
misunderstanding." So, what Jesus does,
what Jesus does, we've looked at it. He
I think he said he's going to respond to
it. So, what does Jesus do? He's the
judge. He's the final judge of all
people according to him. Uh again, the
Old Testament says that Yahweh is the
one who's going to sit on his throne in
judgment. Jesus said, "Yeah, that's
me." The Old Testament says that that
Yahweh is the one who raises the dead.
Jesus says that he's the one who raises
the dead at the resurrection. The people
in their graves are going to hear the
voice of the son of God. Now, that is
very strange if that's oh, that's how we
all are. We're all going to be raised
from the dead by the son of God. If
that's him saying, "Oh, we're all just
the same, and yeah, we we can all you.
You'll be in me and I'll be in you."
Very strange way of putting
things. What his friends say? Now, this
is interesting. Alex quotes Steven in
Acts 7. Now, this is a this is an
awesome passage because this this kind
of proves everything I was saying in my
opening statement. Look at this.
So
Steven rebukes the Jewish leaders in the
harshest terms you can possibly rebuke
someone. Watch what he says. You stiff
necked people. Your hearts and ears are
still uncircumcised. You are just like
your ancestors. You always resist the
Holy Spirit. Was there ever a prophet
your ancestors did not persecute? They
even killed those who predicted the
coming of the righteous one. And now you
have betrayed and murdered him. You who
have received the law that was given
through angels but have not obeyed it.
That is absolutely brutal. Guess what?
They get mad. They don't get
violent. Which what happens? When the
members of the Sanhedrin heard this,
they were furious and nashed their teeth
at him. But Steven, full of the Holy
Spirit, looked up to heaven. Have they
gotten violent yet? Looked up to heaven
and saw the glory of God and Jesus
standing at the right hand of God. Look,
he said, I see heaven open and the son
of man. Remember that? The son of man
standing at the right hand of God. Oh,
you got God and then just someone
else. How many powers in heaven?
When do they get upset? What? Watch when
they get
upset. I see I see heaven open and the
son of man standing at the right hand of
God. Two powers in heaven and Jesus is
one of them. Now watch how they react at
this. They covered their ears and
yelling at the top of their voices, they
all rushed at him, dragged him out of
the city and began to stone him.
Meanwhile, the witnesses laid their
coats at the feet of a young man named
Saul. When do they get
violent? When he says Jesus is one of
the two powers in heaven. That's what
that's exact that is the precise moment
when they get
violent. Jesus is one of the two powers
in heaven. So, keep in mind this
actually supports me, right? I mean,
this is one of this this is one of the
early Christians who gets stoned to
death for saying that Jesus is one of
the two powers in heaven. And if you're
thinking he's just h just a just a
regular guy hanging out in heaven, first
of all, um you might want to check about
someone being in the presence of God and
what sort of person you'd have to be.
But look look what look what uh look
what he I mean Oops. Do I have
it? Oh, I don't have it. Right. Right.
Right after this is when when uh Stephen
I don't have it on a slide. Uh right
after this is when Stephen looks up and
says
what? Lord Jesus receive my spirit. Is
that just a regular guy in the presence
of God up there? No. That's someone
who receives the spirits of people. That
a regular
guy. So Alex thinks this is just God
endowing someone with authority. Um does
not look like that. Jesus seems to be
the authority here. And this not only
gets Steven killed, this sets Paul on a
rampage. Paul says, "I have to wipe this
stuff out." Why? We're told in the book
of Acts, what really sets Paul off, uh
when Ananas is told that Paul is coming,
well, Saul back then, he says that he's
been told to apprehend everyone who
calls on this name. Why is that an
issue? calling on the name. That's
that's how you describe prayer in the
Old Testament. Calling on the name
calling on the name of Yahweh. And Paul
sees the Christians calling on the name
of Jesus the way they're supposed to
call on the name of Yahweh. Why is this
relevant? Paul converts to Christianity
about 2 years after the
crucifixion. When is this taking place?
This is not something that happens 50 or
60 years after the time of Jesus. We
have Christians calling on the name of
Jesus as they call on the name of
Yahweh. And we can trace it to within
two years of Jesus crucifixion. So if
this is a misunderstanding, that's a
pretty big misunderstanding. And Jesus
must be the worst communicator of all
time. Uh Alex brings up the Septu the
Septuagent responding to John. I didn't
uh I I didn't uh rely on the passages
he's responding to. Uh but if you want
to go to the Septuagent in in terms of
uh interpreting uh interpreting the
claims of the New Testament, let's go to
Luke. Luke 6:46. Why do you Jesus says,
"Why do you call me Lord, Lord, and do
not do what I
say?" If you want to talk about the
Septuagent, there's only one other
there's only one other place outside the
outside the Gospels where they use this
Lord
Lord. That's the Septuagent. And it's a
translation of Adoni
Yahweh, God, Adoni, Yahweh. So it's the
Lord Yahweh. But in Greek, they would
translate Adonai and Yahweh as curios.
So it's curios curios in the se in the
septuagent. And here Jesus says, why do
you call me Lord, Lord, and not do what
I say? And so if you want to if you want
to interpret Jesus based on the
Septuagent claiming to be Yahweh, here
you go. There it is. and it's in the
gospel of
Luke. So at the end of the day, uh the
claim is that everything is just some
sort of big
misunderstanding. This is very very very
strange to me because you're basically
saying Jesus was not a good
communicator. You know, you think about
the biatitudes and this the sermon on
the mount and the parable of the
prodigal son and the parable of the good
Samaritan and the golden rule and so on
and so on and so on.
Jesus seems like the best communicator
of all
time. He's a he's careful about what
he's saying and sometimes he unveils
things in different ways. But when he he
makes a point, seems people get this
point. uh if all of his followers just
seem to misunderstand him and start
worshiping him and praying to
him, making doxologies for him and so
on, putting their liturgy around him,
then you're saying Jesus was just a
terrible, terrible communicator. And
that, I have to say, is the one option I
cannot accept
[Applause]
here. All right.
All right. So now, Alex is going to go
up to do his
12minute rebuttal. It gets a bit messy,
I'm afraid, ladies and gentlemen,
because of course we're responding to
each other across purposes. I respond to
an opening. He responds to my opening. I
sort of have to take it back a few
places, but I'll try to make it
interesting. We heard about the angel of
Yahweh and the suggestion that this
might indeed just be Jesus. It might be.
Look, I I don't claim to be
uh the sort of final authority on exesus
here. I'm simply asking you to consider
what you think is a more appropriate
explanation. I've suggested the uh
divine namebearing model as opposed to
the two powers in heaven. And when I
look at passages such as Exodus 23 20 to
21, see, I am sending an angel ahead of
you to guard you along the way. Pay
attention to him and listen to what he
says. Do not rebel against him. He will
not forgive your rebellion since my name
is in him. I just ask which
interpretation lends itself more nicely
to the passages. Uh David's rebuttal
there seemed to suggest that I was under
the impression that Jesus is just some
dude. That is far far from the case
especially in John's gospel where Jesus
seems to posit himself as something of a
model of faith for his disciples. And
for what it's worth this is kind of the
image that I get of Jesus reading
through the gospels. What is he supposed
to be? Something like an idyllic
faithful servant of God and certainly in
a special position. If you include the
the epistles in particular, then Jesus
is of course exalted. Um, but I want to
get into that, but I suppose I should
turn to Philippians chapter 2, which
David mentions. Of course, we're not
talking Jesus's own words anymore, but
it's it's still quite interesting what
people came to believe. the mindset of
Jesus Christ who being in very nature
God did not consider equality with God
as something to be used to his own
advantage but rather made himself
nothing as I'm sure you all know that
word grasp there harpagmon or something
like that I'm not very good at
pronouncing the Greek but it means
something like to
steal to
seize isn't it a bit strange that if
Jesus is God he didn't consider equality
with God as something to be seized
to be stolen. That's how that word is
used in the Greek language. How can he
steal something that's already
rightfully
his? And
indeed, because he then died on the
cross and humbled himself even to death,
therefore he was given the name that was
above all other names. Therefore,
whatever exalted position Jesus is given
here in Philippians 2, and by the way,
he is given it. He's given it because of
his crucifixion. Therefore, he's given
the name above other names. Again, which
interpretation lends itself more nicely
to these
passages. Um, I mean, for what it's
worth, my favorite interpretation, I was
discussing this the other night at
dinner with, well, not with David
actually. without be giving too much
away but is this so-called Adamic uh
James Dunn has written about this the
sort of Adam christologology as applies
to Philippians 2 who being in the very
nature of God this this word uh meaning
like the form of God if we consider that
Jesus is supposed to be the answer to
Adam's sin Adam's sin and Jesus redeems
Adam is made in the image of God and
considers equality with God as something
to be grasped to be seized when he takes
of the fruit and eats it and that is how
man falls so how is man redeemed
While Jesus Christ, though also being
made in the form of a God, in the image
of God, did not consider equality with
God, something to be seized, not him,
but humbled himself. Therefore, Jesus is
exalted. We're told in Hebrews chapter 2
that for a time Jesus is made lower than
the angels, presumably while he's here
on
earth. Again, it just reads to me as if
at least while on earth, Jesus is
certainly not approximating Yahweh. But
he's also not just some
dude. David mentioned the glory that's
given to Jesus in John 17:5. The same
chapter that I was using. Yeah. Verse 5.
Father, glorify me in the presence that
I have with you before the world was
created. Let's keep reading John 17 and
see what Jesus wants to do with that
glory. In fact, the very passage that I
quoted, my prayer is not for them alone.
I pray that all may be one, Father, just
as you're in me and I am in you. May
they also be in us. Blah blah blah.
Immediately afterwards, so they may
brought be brought into complete
unity. Then they will know I've copied
the wrong passage actually. Jesus says
that the glory you've given me, I will
give to
them. In John chapter
17, he says, "The glory you've given me,
I will give to them." the
disciples. We're told in Isaiah in the
book of Isaiah that God shares his glory
with nobody. And this is
sometimes a suggestion that's made is
sometimes that because Jesus says,
"Glorify me, God." In John chapter 17,
he must be God because God shares his
glory with nobody. But people just seem
to forget that in the same chapter Jesus
says that he will give the glory that he
has been given by the father to the
disciples too. Again, all I'm asking you
to consider is however you interpret
these verses where Jesus is given glory,
Jesus is given the judgment. And be bear
in mind that Jesus is given all of these
things, what he then does with those
things, and whether he delegates them to
other people because if he does, then
it's clearly not just something that can
be delegated to God himself. Only God
judges. Only God can judge. But Jesus
says that he will judge. Jesus also
promises judgment over the 12 tribes of
Israel to the disciples. So are the
disciples
God. Jesus forgives sins and only God
can forgive
sins. In John chapter 20 21 he says as
the father has sent me again cathos
cathos as just as the father has sent me
I'm sending you. If you forgive people's
sins their sins will be forgiven. If you
do not their sins will be retained. I'm
told that only God forgives sins. But
then Jesus gives that ability to his
disciples. In other words, all of these
things which are supposed to indicate
that God that Jesus has a special
relationship with God. Of course he
does. But it's a relationship that he
hopes and literally prays that will be
shared with everybody. Also, this Luke
6:46 thing that David put up, I want to
make sure I'm understanding this
correctly. As far as I understand in
Luke 6:46 when it when it quotes Lord
Lord you know and as far as I understand
David was saying that in the Hebrew this
is presumably Yahweh Adonai right is
that right David
Yahweh Adonai in the Hebrew perhaps
he'll address it in his second rebuttal
and then said ah but you know in the
Greek Septuagent this is translated as
curios curios because it's Lord twice
which translation of the Old Testament
are the New Testament writers
the Septuagent. So the passage that they
read would have said curios curious Lord
twice. It wouldn't have said Yahweh and
then Adonite or rather the other way
around I think it is. It would have said
curios curios. So of course they're
willing to use this in Luke's gospel
because it says the same word twice
which to them just means Lord because
that's the that's the translation that
they're reading. Also this idea that
Jesus is a perfect
communicator sort of David is like
mocking this idea saying is am I
supposed to understand Jesus as just
being a terrible communicator? Well, if
you look at the way that the Jews were
interpreting him, like kind of at the
very least, people were deeply
confused. Everybody was confused, not
just his Jewish opponents because they
were hardened of heart. His disciples
regularly struggled with his teachings,
too, asking him to expand and explain
what on earth he meant. It even says at
one point that Jesus was speaking in
parables so that quoting a psalm again,
they will be ever seeing, everlooking
but not seeing, ever hearing but not
understanding. The gospels tell us that
Jesus was speaking intentionally in such
a way that people would misunderstand
him. And then it says, "But when he was
alone with his disciples, he explained
everything." So no, I don't actually
think that Jesus's public ministry was
entirely clear to everybody who was
listening. In fact, that's part of the
point. We're told that Jesus is
constantly trying to hide his identity
because he has to be careful about how
he expresses himself. Which by the way
seems to raise a cont a
contradiction when you consider the fact
that we're told that in at least John's
gospel Jesus is going around willy-nilly
calling himself God. In the full view of
his disciples and also his opponents he
invokes the divine name and anybody
listening would have completely
understood what he was saying. And yet
throughout the synoptic gospels there is
a motif the messianic secret. So it's
called that every time he reveals his
identity he tells them not to tell
anybody. Don't tell them I'm the
Messiah, but it's fine for them to know
that I'm God. I don't know about
that.
Um, I think the best way of
understanding who Jesus is is, like I
say, a sort of idyllic human being. Take
when Jesus walks on the water for
example. Another uh example that's often
given as a high christoologgical moment
because of course in Job 9 it says that
only God treads upon the waves of the
ocean. Sure. But people then also forget
that Peter also walks on the water just
afterwards. But Peter starts sinking and
Jesus says, "You don't have enough
faith." What does that imply? That if
Peter had enough faith, he could have
kept walking on the water. What are we
to take from this? If Jesus is supposed
to be God because he walks on the water,
but then Peter walks on the water, too.
I don't think that's a very good
interpretation.
In other
words, we're told that God forgives
sins, but then the disciples are given
the authority to forgive sins. In John
chapter 20, we're told only God warts on
the water, but then Peter does this
immediately afterwards. We're told that
only God can have the authority to
judge, as David says. But the disciples
are promised judgment over the 12 tribes
of Israel. That's not the only time the
judgment is uh delegated. By the way,
we're told that Jesus explicitly claims
identity with God by saying he and the
father are one. But then Jesus prays
that his disciples will be one in the
same way. We're told that God will share
his glory with nobody else. But Jesus
claims to have had glory with the father
before he was born. But Jesus then says
he wants to share that glory with the
disciples. We're told that Jesus only
rightly accepts worship. This is
interesting. By the way, David flashed
on a few passages of Jesus accepting
worship in the Gospels. The word most
commonly translated as worship in the
New Testament is
progyno which means to bow down or
prostrate before a higher authority. And
of course Jesus received this proaneo
worship therefore he must be
God. If that is the
case then we have to consider the fact
that David in the Septuagent for example
bows down proc before Esau that Joseph's
brothers proc before him when he's
governor of Egypt that the entire nation
of Israel offers proc
worship to King David as well that Lot
procano before two angels. Proskano is
littered throughout the old and also the
New Testament by the way. uh in the
parable of the unmerciful servant when
one of the servants returns he offers
procoo to his master and this is a story
that Jesus is saying also let's not
forget that in
revelation Jesus promises that his true
followers his their enemies will proc
worship before them Jesus himself in
revelation is saying that human beings
will receive proc worship if procaneo
worship is something that only god can
receive then all of these people sinned
all of them. The entire assembly of
Israel sinned when they bowed down
before David. I don't think that's a
good interpretation. There is another
word that's sometimes translated as
worship which is latruo. This is
religious cultic worship that is only
offered to God. Nowhere in the gospels
is this offered to Jesus. How many times
is procao worship? How many times is any
kind of worship accepted by Jesus in
Luke's gospel? Does anybody know? Zero.
The word comes up three times. Twice in
the temptation of the desert where it's
discussed and once at the end after
Jesus has ascended so he can say nothing
about it and in a verse that's contested
in our manuscript traditions. How many
times in Mark does Jesus accept worship?
This time the answer is two, but one of
those is the demon legion. It's usually
translated as throws himself at his feet
before Jesus. And the other is when the
Roman soldiers mockingly worship Jesus.
They offer Proscono. Why? Because he's
the king of the Jews. Because procire
worship is something offered to kings
higher
authorities. I'll keep going perhaps in
my further rebuttal. But if worship is
something that is only due to God, then
there are a lot more sinners in the
Bible than we think. Okay.
Thanks. All right. So now David Wood is
going to do his second six-minute
rebuttal and then that will be followed
up by Alex's six minute rebuttal. All
right. Alex says we're looking for the
best explanation. I would submit that
the best explanation for Jesus claiming
to be one of the two powers in heaven.
um and for claiming to do things like
judge the world and raise the dead at
the resurrection and for why his
followers are praying to him and
worshiping him and calling him God and
the son of God and doing the same thing
doing the exact same thing that Jesus
does namely claiming to be one of the
two powers in heaven and for his enemies
to repeatedly accuse him of blasphemy
ultimately sends him to death and then
people who say the same thing like
Steven uh also uh find themselves uh
being executed And I would say that the
best explanation of that is Jesus was
claiming to be
God. That that's just me. Uh it's like
if if if I met if I met like five if
suppose I never heard a word from Alex,
but I meet like five of his biggest fans
and they say, "Yeah, we love Alex. He's
the Messiah." And then I run into five
of his harshest critics and they say,
"Man, we can't stand that dude Alex. He
thinks he's the Messiah." Even if I
never heard a word from Alex, I'd be
thinking he was claiming to be something
like that. And that's what's giving his
friends and enemies that
indication. Likewise with Jesus, even if
I didn't have any words of Jesus, if I
just know, if I just knew these guys
were were uh people were being put to
death for making these kinds of claims
and that his followers are going around
worshiping him and praying to him, I
would think he's saying
something. Now, uh Alex thinks that
apparently thinks that the best
explanation is this divine uh name
bearing scenario. If so, Jesus did a
really terrible job of getting that
message across. And uh it doesn't seem
like anyone really got the point unless
we do some creative interpretations of
some passages. Alex again quotes Exodus
to say that uh that the the angel of the
Lord is just some representative who
bears the name. Again, I quoted the
exact same book he quoted where Yahweh
says that I'm not going along with you
anymore, which is Yahweh saying that he
was the angel of the Lord who was
guiding them. Um he says that his view
is that Jesus is presented as the ideal
servant of God. The ideal servant of God
convinces people to bow down and worship
him and pray to him and so on. This is
this is what the ideal servant of God
would do. That's a that's a very strange
ideal servant of God since that's kind
of precisely what you shouldn't do if
you're not God. Uh he says that proano
can mean bow down. Yes, you the word
procaneo depends on the cont if it's a
religious context it refers to worship.
If it's but you can yes someone can just
bow down to you out of respect and that
would that would be you can bow down to
a normal human but guess what we have
clearly clearly religious context in
some of these passages for instance
Matthew 14:33 they are freaked out those
who are in the boat worshiped him saying
truly you are the son of God that's a
different sort of context than I want to
ask you for a favor and I want to bow
down out of respect as for Philippians 2
uh he he it sounded like he was uh Dun's
Dun's theory that this is just saying
that when it says who was in very nature
God, it's actually it's actually the
form of God. But this is just saying
that he's a regular he was a a human
being, a human being. And since he found
himself as a human being, like we're all
the image of God. He humbled himself and
therefore he was eventually exalted and
so on. Uh this just it just doesn't
work. Let me just read it. who being in
very nature God or just you can just
make up a translation say image of God
for for fun. Who being in very nature
God did not consider equality with God
something to be used to his own
advantage. Yes, that can mean sees. It
can uh also mean used to his advantage.
You look at what makes sense in context.
Did not consider equality with God
something to be used to his own
advantage. Rather he made himself
nothing by taking the very nature of a
servant being made in human likeness.
the the decision to humble himself is
before is is what led to him being made
in human likeness. This isn't a human
being who's sitting around going, "Hey,
I'm in the image of God. You know, I
could strive to be like God, you know,
like like Adam did, but I'm going to
humble myself instead." This is a divine
being humbling himself by becoming a
human being. And then being found in
appearance as a man, he humbled himself
by becoming obedient to death, even
death on a cross. Therefore, God exalted
in the highest place and gave him the
name that is above every name. That at
the name of Jesus, every knee should bow
in heaven and on earth and under the
earth, and every tongue acknowledged
that Jesus Christ is Lord to the glory
of God the Father. Alex seems to think
that if you're a a human being and you
humble yourself in this way, that God
can just exalt you to to the status of
of Yahweh and apply these passages that
are just Yahweh when when Yahweh says
there there's no one there's no one else
but me. That's what's being quoted there
from Isaiah. As for curios curios um
Alex says well well what would they be
using? They would be using the
Septuagent the Greek translation. Yeah.
And they went to a passage they they
they used the formulation curios curios
which is specifically referring to
Yahweh. That's what Jesus uses. He's
quoting curios curios. He's calling
himself curios curios. The only other
use of that is the septuagent where it
refers
to adoni. So why is Jesus using that?
And again, I only brought up that point
because he he brought up the point about
the Septuagent and using it to interpret
the claims of Christ. So I said, "Fine,
let's go with it." And we got in Luke
and therefore that's him claiming to be
Yahweh. Was Jesus a bad communicator? He
says, "Ah, but Jesus wasn't clear and he
uh veiled his statements." So yes, I
grant all of that. Jesus was a careful
communicator. He was careful about how
he communicated certain things. He tend
he tried to unveil certain things over
time when people were ready for it.
That's not that's not what I consider a
bad communicator. I consider all of that
part of being a very good communicator.
If you're saying that the people who all
heard Jesus all got it wrong somehow, or
that we we don't really have uh the
records of the people who somehow got it
right, that his friends got it wrong
because they continue and they build
their church around him and his enemies
are sentencing him to death. Um I would
say that's a really really really bad
communicator and that just does not line
up. If everyone is concluding the same
thing about this guy that he's claiming
to be God, that he's claiming to be one
of the two powers in heaven, the best
explanation is not some idea that no one
got. The best explanation is very
simple. He was making those claims.
That's why we have all this
evidence. All
right. All right. Check. Check. Check.
Check. Check. Okay. So, now Alex is
going to do his second six-minute
rebuttal. Okay. I suppose I really want
to nail down on this worship point since
I was kind of getting at that at the
end. And David says, "Yeah, procoo can
mean just simply bowing down." But in a
religious context, it means something
else. Like what do you mean? How do you
know that without begging the question?
Like I say, let's actually evaluate.
That's what I was sort of going through.
How many times proca worship is given to
Jesus in the New
Testament or at least that Jesus accepts
it in the New Testament. It doesn't
happen once in Luke's gospel.
It basically doesn't happen once in Mark
because it happens twice. And one of
these is a demon. And one of these,
which I suppose is an interesting thing
to explore in itself. But one of these
is then simply mocking Jesus because
he's the king, why would they consider
mocking him with proso worship if he was
claiming to be king of the Jews? Because
that's what proco means. If procaneo can
mean actually worship of the kind that
latruo usually gets at, that is worship,
cultic worship of a religious figure as
David suggests, here's a riddle for you.
Why isn't it given to Jesus after Jesus
ascends? Why isn't it that people are
offering procao worship after Jesus
ascends? Except at the moment of his
ascension at the end of Luke's gospel,
which as I as I say is contested in our
manuscript tradition anyway. Why
not? Because it refers to a physical
action. Because it's not referring to
worship of the kind that David wants it
to be in this context. In John's gospel,
which we didn't get to, how many times
does Jesus accept
worship? The answer again is
once, just once it happens in John
chapter 9. This is the man who was born
blind, who I mentioned earlier. In verse
38, he says to Jesus, "Lord, I believe."
And he worshiped
him. Except he doesn't say so
in papyrus 75. He doesn't say so in
codec sinaticus. doesn't say so in
codeex washing tonianis. In other words,
this verse isn't present in our earliest
manuscripts. We're pretty confident that
there are elements of the gospels which
are later interpolations. Most famously,
the ending of Mark's gospel, which is
not in a manuscript, and the story of
the adulterous woman, let he who is
without sin cast the first stone, which
are not in our early manuscripts. I'm
interested as to whether David thinks
that there are things in the gospels
which didn't actually happen either
because they're recorded incorrectly or
because they are later interpolations.
But at least in this case of worship, it
seems to be a later interpolation. But
at best we've got one instance of Jesus
accepting worship in John's gospel and
our manuscript evidence seems to suggest
that there's none. If worshiping Jesus
is supposed to be some indication of his
divinity, then why is it only Matthew's
gospel who seems to mention anything to
do with worship and uses a term when
there's another one available to
indicate cultic religious worship to
someone who's divine? Yet, he chooses a
word which just means physical
prostration before someone who has a
higher authority, like I don't know,
maybe the
Messiah. Like the disciples bow down and
worship Jesus. At what point do you
think they began to get the picture that
he was God? They knew that he was the
Messiah for a long time, but I genuinely
don't know when David thinks they began
to realize that this person was God. Do
you think there might be an instance of
them offering procal worship to Jesus
before they'd fully realize that? I
think so. Because procao worship is a
physical action that's given to people
who are of a higher authority. Just to
belabor this point in the Septuagent,
here are some examples of procao
worship. Lot worships two angels in
Genesis. Abraham worships the Hittites.
Isaac blesses Jacob to have all the
nations on earth worship him in Genesis.
Jacob worships Esau. Joseph's brothers
worship him. Abigail worships David's
servants. In 1 Samuel, Saul worships the
dead Samuel in 1 Samuel. The sons of
prophets worship Elijah in 2 Kings.
David worships the temple.
In Psalm 5, all the people of Israel
worship King David in 1 Chronicles. This
is the same term procano. If David wants
to suggest that sometimes this proc
worship can mean cultic religious
worship, even though there's another
word available that people use to mean
that, but it's not being used in this
instance for some reason. I want to know
what that distinction is and how we can
know which kind of worship is being
given without simply begging the
question and saying that well, when it's
given to Jesus, it's obviously of the
religious kind. Otherwise, as far as I'm
concerned, this worship point is
essentially bunk. Some of you might be
thinking, hold on a second. In the
temptation in the
desert, Satan asks Jesus to worship him.
And what does Satan say? Do you know? He
says, "Worship, it is written, worship
God and serve him only." So, you're only
supposed to worship God. And people say
that this is an indication that any
worship of anybody other than God would
be immoral. That interpretation cannot
be the case. Firstly, because it would
condemn all of the people that I've just
listed to be sinners, including the
entire assembly of Israel. That can't be
it. Let's look again at this passage.
Jesus is quoting a passage, which by the
way, he's actually changed in the Old
Testament. The passage that he's quoting
says, "Fear
God rather than worship God." But
besides the point, the word only here
qualifies not the word worship, but the
word serve. Worship God and serve him
only. Worship here is procoo which we
know that Jesus can't be saying only
proaneo towards God because all of these
people including people that Jesus talks
about himself are offered proc worship.
Indeed process worshiped uh is promised
to all of you in revelation. So we know
that he can't mean only worship god in
that sense but only qualifies the word
serve. Worship god and serve him only.
What is the word serve? Which which
Greek word is translated in this passage
to serve? Does anybody know?
Latruo cultic religious worship. So this
is a reaffirmation of point that proc
worship is fine but latrua worship is
something special that can only be be
given to God. The key text here is James
Dun's um did the early Christians
worship God? And as he rightly points
out there is no talk anywhere once in
the entire New Testament of latruo
worship being offered to Jesus. Why not?
All right. Okay. So, that concludes
Alex's second rebuttal round. We're
going to move to open discussion. All
right. All right. All right.
Well, shall we spark it off, gentlemen?
Whatever you like. Let's do it. Open
dialogue. Who would like to take the
lead?
Uh well, I have some questions perhaps
to ask David about his position on
Jesus's relationship to the father with
particular regards to the authority that
he derives from the the father. So one
question for example, why do you think
that Jesus
prays before raising Lazarus from the
dead?
Um the the Old Testament says that God
is the God of all flesh. If um if a
divine being were to become incarnate as
is claimed of Jesus and that divine
being really became a flesh and blood
human being like Jesus then um if he
is if he's also had an eternal
relationship with the
father then I I don't know if I'd expect
him to be an atheist when he entered
into creation. So I in other words in
other words if if if the Christian
picture is correct you've got father and
son for all eternity son enters into
creation
um what's he going to be an atheist if
he is going to if as part of it is if
he's going to be the ideal human or
something like that. Yeah. And so the
son of man, one might say, as far as uh
as far as what Jesus is going to do, um
you would continue the eternal
relationship that you've had with the
father and you would do that through
prayer. So what I mean to say is could
Jesus have have risen Lazarus from the
dead of his own accord on his own
authority?
I suppose. Yeah, you suppose
that all authority has been given to
himself. Been given to him by God,
right? which the way that I read that is
that the father has delegated the
authority that is rightfully his to
Jesus. And it's often said to me that
Jesus raising people from the dead of
his own authority is actually an
indication of his divinity because we
have Old Testament passages of people
raising people from the dead like Elijah
and Elisha. And the point is always made
that well they pray before they they
rise from the dead. Jesus doesn't pray.
But before he raises Lazarus in Johnap
11, he looks upward and says,"Father, I
thank you for having heard me. I know
that you always hear me, but I've said
this for the sake of the crowd standing
here so they may believe that you have
sent me." And when he says this, he
cries out with a loud voice, "Lazarus,
come out." So Jesus is not only praying
before raising Lazarus, but also saying
that I always do this. It's just I'm
doing it right now publicly. So there's
no confusion that you're the one who
sent me to do this. And so even in
instances where Jesus appears to perform
miracles of his own accord, such as
calming the storm or indeed raising
other people from the dead, like the the
widow's child, he tells us here in
John's gospel that he always is in
communication with God beforehand, but
right now he's saying so publicly so
that people will know that he sent him.
Why does Jesus need to pray before he
raises Lazarus from the dead? Um, I
mean, this is the exact same chapter
where Jesus declares himself the
resurrection and the life. That's right.
And it's in the same book where Jesus
says that he's the one who raises the
dead at the resurrection. Everyone who's
in their graves
will hear the voice of the son of God.
Mhm. And so, uh, if if you're if you're
thinking that when we talk about Jesus,
we're thinking of him as some rogue
deity who does things on his own, I
mean, that's basically the the entire
meaning of John chapter 5. John chapter
5 is basically one response to this. Um,
Jesus
uh
Jesus heals on the Sabbath. And this
freaks him out because they say, "Hey,
what are you doing?" He says, "Well, the
father's working until now. I'm working
too. Yeah. And so since the father's
working, I get to work. You all don't
get to work. I get to work. And then
they accuse him of claiming to be equal
to God. And then he explains it that
it's a verse that Muslims use. They say
he says by my own self I can do nothing.
But if you look at what he's saying,
it's I can do nothing separately from
the father. But that's the same chapter
where he claims that he's the final
judge. Where he claims that he's the one
who raises the dead at the resurrection.
And he explains it and says um for the
father judges no one but has given all
judgment to the son that all may honor
the son just as they honor the father.
The only way you'd honor the son the
same way you you honor the father is if
they have the same nature and
attributes. You wouldn't honor anyone
else like you honor God. Interesting. Do
you believe that? So Jesus is saying
that the reason he's the one who judges
everything is because is so that we
honor him the same way we honor the
father. That doesn't that that sounds Do
you believe do you believe that the
father has a distinct loving
relationship to the son compared to the
loving relationship he has to all of us
say?
Yep. Only because I' I've heard you make
this point before that he says that it's
that word as is quite important what you
just said so that he will honor uh so
that they will honor me just as they
honor the father. That word just as is
cathos which I mentioned earlier. That's
also used when Jesus says, "So they will
know that you have loved me just as you
have loved them." So if we if we're
going to be consistent in our usage of
the term here, if if Jesus saying like
uh that they will honor you just as
they'll honor me just as uh just as you
honor the father, then the loving
relationship has to be treated in the
same way. Right. Well, I think you could
say I'm trying to think if you say that,
you know, I could say I love this person
just as I love my wife. And yeah, you'd
be right. I could say, well, I just mean
I love both of them, but not in, you
know, that wouldn't necessarily be
saying I love that person exactly as I
That's why there are two words in the
Greek. That's why there's like the word
for. No, and finally, I'm talking about
you have to interpret words in context.
And what's what's the context of this?
It's Jesus. Jesus claims Jesus claims
that that that since the father is
working, he's working also. Mhm. And
it's interesting because the discussion
among the rabbis was does God work on
does God work on the Sabbath? And so
Jesus is working. So God works on the
Sabbath because he's upholding and
sustaining the universe. Therefore, I
get to work on the Sabbath as well. And
then hey, you're claiming to
be like they think he's claiming to be
another God. And he clarifies, no, no,
no. by myself I can do nothing. He
points us he he points this out and in
this context he's the final judge. And
so it's you will honor the son just as
you honor the father. There in context
it would be very strange to say well I
just mean honor me in some sense like
you honor the father but not not in that
way. It's I mean the old testament
Yahweh is the one who sets up his throne
to judge. Jesus is the one who says all
judgment is given to him. Given Yeah.
Yeah. And so if it's if all judgment is
given to him and keep in mind the Old
Testament Yahweh is the one who's going
to judge and you're saying Yeah. but
it's given to Jesus.
Yeah. And he says it's so that we honor
him the same way we honor the father.
Yeah. Okay. So I want to talk about this
Sabbath moment because this is quite
important. This is in John chapter 5 as
well. This whole episode sort of hinges
on the idea that Jesus is working on the
Sabbath. He says, "My father is working.
So am I." So your interpretation of this
is to say that well my father in heaven
that is God is working on the Sabbath so
so am I therefore I'm God. This story of
Jesus working on the Sabbaths is
reported in multiple gospels in Mark's
gospel when he's found working on the
Sabbath. And the Pharisees say to him,
this is Mark chapter 2. Look why are
they doing that which is not lawful on
the Sabbath? What does Jesus say in
response?
Have you not heard what David did? Have
you not read what David did when he and
his companions were hungry and in need
of food and they enter the house of God
and take the food which is not lawful on
the Sabbath? So
Jesus justifies his breaking of the
Sabbath by referring to another human
being who also broke the Sabbath. He
then tells us that the Sabbath was made
for mankind and not mankind for the
Sabbath. A very famous quote. The
Sabbath was made for man and not man for
the Sabbath. Bearing in mind that
although the son of man is lord of the
seven. Yes. Bear in mind that although
in the in the Greek the definite article
is given to Jesus when he uses the term
son of man, it's complicated by the fact
that son of man without the definite
article is just a way of saying human
being. So there are some scholars such
as Morris Casey who believe that these
son of man sayings have been corrupted
at least some of them from originally
saying a son of man or the son of man in
the sense of just meaning a human being.
Now, why would that interpretation be
correct here? Because Jesus says firstly
when he's accused of breaking the
Sabbath, he says, "Well, David did the
same thing. Was David sinning?" The
implication is no, which means it can't
just be God who breaks the Sabbath. He
then says that the Sabbath was made for
man, humans, not humans or man for the
Sabbath. Therefore, he says the word is
therefore, the son of man is Lord of the
Sabbath. If the son of man in some
context just means a human being, that's
how early church fathers interpreted it.
For example, in fact, some of the early
church fathers translated the son of man
as the son of Mary because they thought
it was Jesus indicating that he was the
son of a human being and he was only
born of Mary. Given that undertone for
this phrase, the son of man, how else
can I read this passage except Jesus
saying, "Yeah, I'm working on the
Sabbath." So did David, and that wasn't
wrong. The Sabbath was made for mankind.
Therefore, mankind is Lord of the
Sabbath. If it's only God who can work
on the Sabbath, then why does Jesus
appeal to David? Um, you're you're
you're talking about two completely
different passages. You're talking about
this this situation and Jesus I was
talking to a Jewish guy in Israel and he
he was he's not a Christian, but he
said, "Hey, Jesus way won. Jesus way
actually won. Jesus Jesus the way of
Jesus won." Oh, sure. He he viewed Jesus
as like a a religious reformer um sent
against uh religious extremism and so
on. Um there Jesus is talking about like
preserving life and so on. The
accusation in John in John five is
different but I'm I mean I'm I'm
pointing to John because you you're
going with John. In John five he says
the father's working
and so he gets to work too. That's
right. And again if you read this
there's there's no way to interpret this
as Jesus claiming to be some you know
just another human being or something
like that. Well, I don't think Jesus is
claiming to be just another human being.
But although we are talking about two
different passages here, if the reason
that Jesus gives because bear in mind
there are multiple ways to interpret
this when he says, "Well, God's working
so why not I?" There are multiple ways
to interpret this. Either Jesus is again
quite explicitly claiming to be God,
which again is quite mystifying given
that this doesn't seem to provoke the
same kind of reaction. And if it's well
recognized that God is the Lord of the
Sabbath and Jesus is claiming himself as
a title, the son of man to be Lord of
the Sabbath or in this instance just
claiming the authority because God is
working so so am I. It's strange that it
doesn't cause the same kind of fuss. But
the other interpretation is that Jesus
is saying, well, if God can work on the
Sabbath, why not anybody else? If God
can work, why not me? And that just
doesn't your interpretation just doesn't
square with me with Mark's gospel. I
mean the question I asked is why does he
refer to David in justifying talking
about we're talking about John. Yes you
can you can you can have you can have
different reasons for doing things in
different situations. I mean as far as
John so Jesus because he was doing these
things on the Sabbath the Jewish leaders
began to persecute him. In his defense
Jesus said to them my father is always
at his work to this very day and I too
am working. For this reason, they tried
all the more to kill him. Not only
because he was breaking the Sabbath, but
was even calling God his own father,
making himself equal with God. Yes. And
so that's when Jesus goes and and if
he's trying to say that if he's trying
to say something about it's okay to
break the Sabbath or you don't have to
work on the Sabbath anymore or something
like that. It's a it's a strange
direction to go in that he makes all
these claims. Um, he can do only what
the father sees because whatever the
father does, the son also
does. For just as the father raises the
dead and gives them life, even so the
son gives life to whom he is pleased to
give it. Mhm. The father judges no one,
but is entrusted all judgment to the son
that all may honor the son just as they
honor the father. Whoever does not honor
the son does not honor the father.
That's when he goes on to say that he's
the one who raises the dead. A time is
coming and has now come when the dead
will hear the voice of the son of God
and those who hear will live. For as the
father has life in himself, so he has
granted the son also to have life in
himself. And he has given him authority
to judge because he is the son of man.
And then he goes on to say that uh the
dead are going to be raised. My point is
zeroing in on one little point and
saying ah well you know maybe this is
just you're missing kind of the big
picture. This is but I'm noticing the
words granted and given or authority
there. Uh this idea that Jesus raises
the dead is not exactly clear in John
chapter 5. Like if we if we look at the
words that we're actually dealing with
here, the father judges no one but has
entrusted all judgment to the
son. Presumably the father could judge
if he wanted to. He's made a decision to
entrust this to the son. Meaning that
the son doesn't have this power
necessarily. If the son has this power
necessarily, it's not something that
needs to be entrusted to him in the way
that the father then would not have it.
He then says, "Very truly I say to you,
whoever hears my word and believes him
who has sent me has eternal life." And
goes on to say that the dead will hear
the voice of the son of God and those
who hear will live. The voice of the son
of God. Yeah. Now, he's the son of God,
right? Jesus. That's right. Agreeing
that he's claiming to be the son of God.
Yeah. So, they'll hear his voice and
they'll be raised from the dead. But how
do we like who is doing the raising
here? And how do you know?
Um, you wait. You're you're saying we're
going to hear people are going to So
you're saying someone else is raising
them? God, when they hear the voice of
the son of God. So they're dead. They're
just bones. They hear the voice of the
son of God and then someone else raises
them. For as the father has given has
life in himself, so he has granted the
son to also have life in himself. Life
in himself. Yes. Any power that Jesus
has here is given to him by the father.
Why is Jesus if God in need of being
given this power by the father?
Um you not you have the this is the
exact same issue that you have in um in
Daniel 7 where the uh the son of man
coming with the clouds of heaven
approaches the ancient of days and he is
given authority, glory and sovereign
power. So it's why is he being given
authority and glory and sovereign power?
Yeah. But even before that, it's the son
of man coming with the clouds of heaven.
That's how he approaches. But again,
it's Yahweh who comes with the clouds.
So he's Yahweh and then something
happens. And then he's he's given the
son of man is Yahweh. Do you think that
that was how Daniel 7 was interpreted by
anybody before Daniel saw a vision.
That's right. But this this is this is
this is one of the issues as far as the
this is one of the issues that comes up
in um in the two power the two powers in
heaven because it's again Yahweh is the
only one who comes with the clouds in
the Old Testament. And here you have the
son of man who receives uh worship and
so on and is worshiped by all nations
and but notice he approaches he
approaches and then he's he's given
authority, glory and sovereign power.
Mhm. But if you if you if you line that
up with the creed in Philippians, if you
line that up with John 1 and so on, you
get you get kind of a big picture and
you can you can take like John 1:1. In
the beginning was the word, the word was
with God, the word was God, and then the
word became flesh and dwelt among us.
That's after all things are created
through him. And you find the same thing
in Philippians 2 early Christian creed
uh when it's uh in your relationships
with with one another have the same
mindset as Christ Jesus who being in
very nature God did not consider
equality with God something to be used
to his own advantage um rather he made
himself nothing taking the very nature
of a servant. So these are you you have
someone who is in nature God over here.
Someone who is the word who through whom
all things are created and then enters
creation
and if you so then lives as Jesus dies
and I would I would interpret it since
you have uh the ending in Matthew where
Jesus approaches and he's worshiped
there and he says that all authority in
heaven and earth has been given to him.
M so the idea is he becomes a servant.
He's in very nature God. He takes on the
nature of a servant and then he lives as
a servant. And the the irony of the
statement where where he says the son of
man came not to be served but to serve
and to give his life as a ransom for
many. The irony there is he's the son of
man. He's supposed to be served in by
all. And he says that he came to serve.
And so he's living as a servant during
this life. Then he dies. He rises from
there's there's a lot here, right? Yeah.
I I want to go right back because we
started with this idea of the son of man
coming on the clouds meaning that he's
Yahweh. Do you think that's how Daniel
interpreted his vision? Do you think
that's how I believe Daniel saw a vision
and recorded his vision? Do you think
that's how the Sanhedrin interpreted
Daniel 7? When Jesus comes for his trial
and he says and he quotes Daniel 7 and
says that you'll see the son of man
riding on the clouds of heaven. Do you
think that the problem there was that
Jesus was claiming to be God and that's
something that no human being can do?
Because Daniel 7 is part of the Jewish
scripture. They were expecting the
coming of this son of man. So if it's
obvious that the son of man was going to
be Yahweh, then the Sanhedrin should
have expected that the coming son of man
would have been Yahweh. They might have
thought that Jesus wasn't him. But do
you think that the Sanhedrin were
expecting whoever the rightful son of
man was who was to come would be
identical to Yahweh? And if not, why did
they not read that into the passage as
obviously as you think that they should
have done? People were basically
confused by these passages. That's the
impression you get. They go in all sorts
of different directions and oh, this is
referring to the Messiah. No, this is
referring to some sort of angel. No,
this is referring to this. No, that's
I'm talking about what the text says,
the son of man comes with the clouds of
heaven. All before that, all before
that, it's always Yahweh who comes on
the clouds. And so if you were looking
at that and you didn't if you if you
didn't have the idea of wait a minute,
it it just can't be. It it's impossible
that that is referring to God because
you've got the ancient of days right
there. If you're not reading I and
really I I don't know I don't even know
what to do if you're saying that I'm not
talking about you. I'm talking about
anyone. If you're reading that and
going, "No, it doesn't seem like this is
God. He comes with the clouds of heaven,
but then he's worshiped by all nations
and has an ever an everlasting kingdom."
Mhm. If you're just reading that, if if
put it this way, if you didn't have the
ancient of days in the picture and
you're reading this description, comes
in the cloud of heavens, worship all
nations, say obviously God. Yes. The the
the mystery comes in. The mystery comes
in when it's wait a minute, we've got
the ancient of days here. So, this is
sounding like That's right. two divine
beings and we just can't real quick. So,
we we've gone through about 20 minutes.
David, are you comfortable staying here
or do you want to ask Alex some
questions now?
We
we just of course the point was or is in
the christoologgical dispute that Jesus
is accused of blasphemy at his trial and
that this is evidence that he was
claiming to be God through his
identification with the divine son of
man because that's how it's
interpreted by the high priest because
he accuses him of blasphemy. Does that
mean that the high priest was expecting
the son of man to be Yahweh himself? Do
you think that that is the
interpretation that the high priest had
of the Danielic vision of the son of
man? I would say they would obviously
have interpreted the uh that that
passage in Daniel or claimed to be the
son of man in in that sense if you were
just if you're just saying hey I'm a son
of man I think they'd be fine with it.
Um well yeah of course in in the Aramaic
in which Daniel 7 is written it's one
like a son of man one like bar nash
which just means one like a human being.
Yeah. So you you'd clarify that and
that's the point like like a human being
and yet he comes with the clouds of
heaven. So he's he's coming with clouds
of heaven. He's Yahweh and yet he's like
the son of a man. That's right. You
understand history? As far as as far as
how they would interpret it, they could
have a range of interpretations that we
don't know what this means, but we know
that the the guy who built my cousin's
table in Nazareth should not be making
this claim. Sure. So, is that enough to
be So, suppose that their interpretation
was a a messianic vision of Daniel 7.
This carpenter claiming to be the
Messiah, would that have been enough to
accuse him of blasphemy? Claiming to be
the Messiah is not a not a death
sentence. All all kinds of So, the
reason I'm pressing this point is
because when I say, did the high priest
believe that the son of man was going to
be Yahweh himself? I think that's quite
implausible. And I think you recognize
that in saying, well, look, there are
loads of ideas that they could have had.
was quite confusing. But if Jesus
wouldn't be accused of blasphemy for
merely claiming to be the Messiah, if
you had a messianic interpretation, he
wouldn't be accused of blasphemy for
claiming to embody the nation of Israel.
If you have the idea that the son of man
represents Israel, which is another
view, it has to be Israel comes on the
clouds of it has to be and is worshiped
by all nations. I'm not that's my
interpretation. I'm saying that in the
history of the interpretation of Daniel
7, that has been a popular
interpretation. Of course, the four
beasts which come before represent
different nations and the one like the
son of man is Israel. But the question
I'm asking you is surely you recognize
that if the idea is that claiming to be
the Messiah or something like that is
not enough for a death sentence. That's
right. Then what Jesus has to have done
in that trial in order to get a death
sentence must have been to say something
that the high priest immediately
interpreted as him claiming to be
Yahweh. That means that he has to expect
that the coming son of man would be
Yahweh himself.
I understand what the high priest
thought of Daniel's vision. one, you're
you're you just made an awesome case for
me, right? If he's just thinking of if
he's just thinking of the the son of man
coming with the clouds of heaven uh as
the Messiah, then oh, okay, this guy
claimed to be the Messiah. Let's uh
let's uh maybe we have to deal with the
Romans or something like that. But it's
not it's not uh it's not this uh terrier
blasphemy sort of thing. Um what you
find in that passage, people struggle
with that. Again, the reason the reason
is because it sounds like it's talking
about Yahweh when the ancient of days is
Yahweh. That's it. So, you come up, you
try to you try to explain it in other
ways. Could this be the Messiah? That
does, it just doesn't fit. Could this be
the nation of Israel? It doesn't fit.
There all these interpretations, but
it's clear if a guy says, "You will see
the son of man coming with a uh at the
right hand of power and coming with the
clouds of heaven." Yeah. Doesn't seem
like they were taking that to just be a
claim to be the Messiah. that
interpretation and and you're right that
I'm bolstering the case here that Jesus
must have been claiming to be Yahweh.
What I'm saying is that if your position
is correct and that is the only thing
that he could have been accused of
blasphemy for, then you have to
presuppose that the high priest had that
interpretation of Daniel 7, which which
just seems so implausible to me that
that's what they thought Daniel 7 meant.
That that's what they thought at that
time that it meant that this son of man
who they did expect to come would be
Yahweh himself. Is is that what you
think they they thought? Because you
have to for this to run. I don't have
the records of the high priest. If he
says, "This guy just claimed to be the
son of man coming with the clouds of
heaven." And again, this if you just
read the if you just read the passage,
if you just read in Daniel 7, yeah, if
you didn't have the ancient of days
there, it would be indisputable. This
talking about this talking about God,
but you've got the ancient of days
there. So, what's the context of this
first century? They're dealing with this
two powers in heaven issue, and they
don't know how to deal with it. They're
coming they're coming up with all sorts
of explanations for what they for what
this second power is. And then Jesus
claims to be one of them. When does the
two powers in heaven uh like idea heresy
if you want to call it that now? Like
when does that begin to emerge? Uh BC.
What evidence do you have of the
popularity of the 2 heaven idea in
second temple Judaism? you well I mean
the the main discussion that's that's
used like in uh in um uh in Seagal's in
Seagull's book
is the the later rabbitic commentaries
but so you have yeah in like the late 1
and 2 century right
yeah that's when that's when they're
talking about because it's a big deal uh
yeah that well that's when that's when
Jewish orthodoxy is is forming so in
other words it's a relatively fringe
position beforehand
no it's it's it was fairly popular
what's your evidence for uh as far as I
understand it's it's a relatively fringe
position. Okay. So, you have one you
have one you have all these issues that
are in the Old Testament, but then you
have the the Targums. You have the
Tarans that are that are um they're
they're putting Old Testament passages
into Aramaic and so on and they start
giving some interesting uh some
interesting translations of uh of some
of these passages and so on and
treating there's a lot of other issues
like even with even with the name and
with the word and that's why boy that's
why Borieran says the ideas the the
ideas are already there because you have
passages where they're in where they're
interpreting uh the word where they're
interpreting uh the word of God as a
personal agent and so on. So the idea is
that uh that uh that would you know
here's drawing a parallel between that
and and John's gospel. Here's James
James McGrath on on the two powers. The
evidence surveyed thus far gives no
support for dating the origins of the
controversy even to the second century.
It is of course possible that the
controversy did arise in the second
century, but it has not yet been
sufficient had sufficient impact to
leave any clear or explicit trace in the
traditions and literature from that
period.
Um you when you ha when you have when
you have the rabbis forming Jewish
orthodoxy, they're clearly responding to
the issue of the two powers in heaven.
Yeah. When's that happening? Yeah,
that's later. But they're talking about
things that things that happened
earlier. But because remember what we're
talking about here is the idea of the
son of man that the high priests would
have had at Jesus's trial. If the 2,00
heaven idea is something that only
emerges in the late 1st and second
century. No, that's that's when it's
being labeled a heresy. That's when
they're declaring it a heresy and
they're set they're setting out. What
I'm asking is is why is it that if this
is already a controversy that has
emerged and is extent to the ex to to
the extent that the high priest believes
it then why is it leaving no trace in
our traditions and literature from that
period? Why is it why in other words
what traditions do you have from what
what commentaries are you talking about
from the first century? Well, that's a
that's a silence thing because I'm I
don't have commentary I could what
commentaries do I have that don't
mention it? That's a bit of a broad
question. And I'm asking what to do if
you're if the rabbis are talking about
these earlier controversies and they're
dealing with because you have you have
the Christians went went one way with
it. You had the Gnostics became an issue
for the Gnostics because the Gnostics
interpreted they believed in the two
powers in heaven and they said they're
basically in conflict. The two powers
are in conflict and so the Gnostics ran
with that and then you had uh Jewish
mystics, Jewish mystics who were running
with the issue. Do you think the
Gnostics believed in the two powers in
heaven heresy as as you've described it?
They believe they believed in the two
powers.
They went they went in a completely
different direction. So they so the
Christian direction was father was
father and son. You've got father and
son. You've got son of man coming with
the clouds in ancient of days. You've
got um God and the word of God. You've
got Paul calling u the father God and
calling Jesus Lord and so on. So you see
it all over there. They have the two
powers, but the two powers are in
harmony and have always been so. Yeah.
The Gnostics believed in the two powers
and they believe that they're in they're
believe that they're in
conflict. And so then you so anyway the
point okay look I and I I really don't
know here but I'm I think that this
hinges on the evidence that the two
powers in heaven idea is a popular
enough
controversy in the time of Jesus's in
Jesus's lifetime that the high priest
seek would have believed it and and as
far as I can see the you can tell what
he believed by how he reacts. So, so you
do think that this is what he believed
then like you're committing yourself to
that view. In other words, that this is
the view that the high priest had of
Daniel 7 that the son of man would be
Yahweh that even before Jesus came
along, this high priest must have read
Daniel 7. No idea. He have a range of
ideas. So, you just say you can't have
no idea because if your if your whole
claim is that Jesus couldn't have been
accused of blasphemy for anything other
than claiming to be God. I've never said
that in this instance, like what other
interpretation of Daniel 7 do you think
would would this Let me put it this way.
What interpretation other than the one
that I've just described of Daniel 7
could the high priest have that would
cause him to accuse Jesus of blasphemy
based on the words that he said? As as
far as we you can tell in commentary,
they can't figure out what it means,
right? And
so the question is how is the high
priest interpreting what Jesus is
saying? So how are they interpreting
what Jesus is saying? And he Jesus is
identifying himself as the son of man
who they already expected to come from
Daniel 7. And they interpret that as him
claiming to be Yahweh.
It really looks like that. I think
that's what you have to say, right? You
have to say that they think he's
claiming to be Yahweh. But in order to
say that, you have to believe that that
is how he interpreted Daniel 7. Look,
no, I don't. He could have a range of
interpretations and like like put it
this way. Look at what the high priest
is doing when he says, "Don't keep us in
suspense any longer. Are you the Christ,
the son of the the son of the blessed?"
He's asking for clarification on what
he's saying. What are you saying? What
are you telling us? Okay. So, bearing in
mind that one interpretation of Daniel 7
throughout history, even after the
advent of Christianity, is that Daniel 7
is a messianic prophecy about the coming
Messiah. If Jesus is asked, "Are you the
Messiah?" And he responds by quoting
Daniel 7. If one of the interpretations
of Daniel 7 is that it's talking about
the Messiah, then why would they not
just think he was claiming to be the
Messiah? They he obviously didn't give
them them them that impression if they
they said he deserves death for it. And
by the way, by the way, this is
connected. You can you can actually tell
what happens. I mean, you brought up the
passage in Acts 7. I mean, Stephen
Steven is giving his entire case for
belief in Jesus as the Messiah. They
never get violent. Then he rebukes them
the harshest way you can possibly. All
your you you killed all the your
ancestors killed all the prophets and
you guys killed the Messiah. Mhm. If
they're just going to get ticked off at
rebuke or insults or something like
that, that would have been the time to
do it. It's when he says, "I see the son
of man." It's when I see the son of man.
That's when they cover their ears. They
cover their ears. They charge him and
they kill him. So, you can do the same
thing. Why are they inter why why is it
why why are they interpreting as why
aren't they interpreting that as he's
just saying that Jesus is the Messiah?
That's exactly right. Yeah. Why do they
think that? We got we we got to we got
to move to to Q&A. We've gone way over
the open dialogue. So, if you have a
question, line up over there while I let
you guys finish your thoughts. Um, guys,
hey. Oh,
gosh. Two.
All right. So, check it out. Right here
where Ray is. Right here where Ray is.
You guys go to Ray Rock. Right here in
the very front. Check. Check. Check.
Yes. We get four minutes on the on the
clock for the conclusions.
All right. In my opening statement, I
point out you you basically have a
controversy.
Um, we know that there's a controversy
uh going on and we see how we see how
Christians are responding to that
and basically up until orthodoxy defines
the uh two powers issue as a heresy. Um,
you had a wide range of views, a wide
range of uh interpreting these various
texts and so on. It's pretty clear what
happens
when Jesus comes along and we looked I
actually qu it's interesting I quoted
multiple passages in Mark and I quoted
uh Q as far as Jesus saying that
um all things have been handed over to
him by his father. No one knows the son
except the father. No one knows the
father except the son and anyone to whom
the son chooses to reveal him. You have
I quoted those because I assumed that
that he was going to reject John. And so
I was quoting the uh the the some of our
earlier material and then the creed in
Philippians and so on where know if you
noticed but everyone seems to be doing
the same thing and it's the same issue
that arises in the Old Testament. You
have Yahweh sending Yahweh. You have
Yahweh sending the angel of the Lord but
the angel of the Lord is Yahweh and
Yahweh says that he's the angel. You
have the uh ancient of days and the son
of man coming with the clouds of heaven.
So you have these issues and people are
confused about it. But then you look to
the New Testament, they're doing the
exact same thing that was going on in
the Old Testament, but now they're
defining it as father, son, God, and the
word, but the word is is also God. Um
Paul saying God, the father is God and
Jesus is Lord. Um and they also bring in
the the son of man in the ancient of
days with uh with Jesus and so on. So
you've got all these pastors, they're
all doing the same thing. It's kind it's
pretty clear. It's pretty clear what's
going on. And the question is, we look
we look at what Jesus says. He sounds
like he's claiming to be one of the two
powers in heaven in multiple ways. We
look at what Jesus does. He's claiming
to do things like judge the world and
raise the dead at the resurrection. We
look at what his followers say. Uh we
look at what his followers do. We look
at what his enemies say. We look at what
his enemies do. And everything we can
look at gives the indication that this
guy was making claims that cause people
to either uh worship him and start
praying to him and doxologies and so on
or saying that this guy has to
die. And if that's all just a
miscommunication, this is like beyond
anything else. You want to say Jesus
wasn't the greatest communicator and so
on because he slowly unveiled things for
people who weren't ready to hear it. Uh
that's very different from saying
everyone got the message horribly
horribly wrong. And so I just wanted to
conclude here with uh the last minute uh
wanted to revisit the
uh famous quote from CS Lewis. Famous
quote from CS Lewis um that the
trillemma the problem with the trillemma
was that it didn't rule out uh it didn't
include certain other options. So, it's
presented as Lord, liar, lunatic, but
you've got the legend possibility that
it doesn't include. What if all this is
later legendary development? Well, we've
seen that can't be the case because
everyone concludes this. It's all over
the place. It's in our earliest
material. We can trace this back to two
year within two years of the formation
of the church when Paul is persecuting
the church. What's he doing? He was
persecuting people for calling on the
name of Jesus the way they're calling on
the name of the Lord. This means that
the early church um had this view. And
the other option would
be Jesus is a terrible communicator and
everyone misunderstood him. And that I I
just have to say again given how Jesus
taught, I can't believe that everyone
was horribly misunderstanding. And so
when we rule those out, I think we can
agree with CS Lewis who said, "I'm
trying to prevent anyone saying the
really foolish thing that people often
say about him. I'm ready to accept Jesus
as a great moral teacher, but I do not
accept his claim to be God." That is the
one thing we must not say. A man who was
merely a man and said the sort of things
Jesus said would not be a great moral
teacher. He would either be a lunatic on
the level with the man who says he is a
poached egg or else he would be the
devil of hell. You must make your
choice. Either this man was and is the
son of God or else a mad man or
something worse. You can shut him up for
a fool. You can spit at him and kill him
as a demon. Or you can fall at his feet
and call him Lord and God. But let us
not come with any patronizing nonsense
about his being a great human teacher
or a terrible communicator. He has not
left that open to us. He did not intend
to.
All right. Sure.
Alex for a minute closing.
All right. For a minute closing from
Alex. Yeah. I mean there I guess there
are a few important things to say. First
is that I totally forgot in that entire
section that I really really did want to
hear what David thinks about Jesus
implying all throughout John chapter 17
that the relationship he has with the
father is the same as the relationship
the father and he wish to have with all
Christian believers. I find it quite
stunning that when specifically asked to
clarify his christoologgical position,
he describes his relationship with the
father in terms that he then attributes
to first his disciples and then the rest
of Christian believers. Absent
everything else that we've been saying,
that alone should be pretty stunning.
What can it possibly mean for Jesus to
describe his relationship to the father
and then say, "In the same way that I'm
in him and he's in me, I want you all to
be in us so we can all be one, all of
us." What can that possibly mean? We
didn't even get to discuss this. Maybe
some people in the Q&A have some
answers, but on its own, that is enough
to raise some serious question marks. Of
course, a lot of David's case has relied
on this two powers heresy, and we were
sort of getting a bit caught in the
weeds there about the dating. I read a
quote from James McGrath, which I didn't
finish because it's quite long, but he
goes on to say, and this is in uh the
only true God, early Christian
monotheism in its Jewish context. He
says, of course, conversely, the absence
of evidence for the existence of the
heresy in this period surveyed so far
does not prove that it did not yet
exist. Of course, that's true. However,
in view of the clear palemic against two
powers in later writings and the
complete absence of such pmic in earlier
writings, this at least strongly
suggests the possibility that the two
powers only became an issue for whatever
reason in the period after those
documents were put in their present
form. In other words, this two powers
discussion doesn't seem to crop up at
all until it's too late to have
influenced the high priest. And I want
to know why I suppose that's the case. I
want to know why it is that Jesus also
says that the glory he receives from the
father will be given to the disciples
and given to everybody else. I want to
know why Jesus is given the authority to
forgive sins which at least is
interpreted by his Jewish opponents as
something only God can do and then gives
it to his disciples the same authority
at the end of chap John chapter 20
saying as the father has sent me I'm now
sending you. What is going on here? Why
is Jesus passing on all of these divine
prerogatives in unity to his disciples
in precisely the way that he got them
from the
father? If any of these instances, any
of these divine and the same thing with
judgment, by the way, which David keeps
coming back to, which God also delegates
to other people. Again, we haven't heard
much response on these ideas of it's not
just Jesus who gets to judge, but Jesus
also delegates that judgment. The
example I gave was delegating judgment
of the 12 tribes of is Israel to his
disciples, which is something we're
pretty sure he historically actually
said because he says that the 12 of you
will sit on 12 thrones judging the tw 12
tribes of Israel. Meanwhile, Judas is
currently present. So, it's likely he
actually said this because it's not
something a later Christian writer would
make up. There are Christian
interpretations as to why he would have
still said 12, of course, but it's an
unnatural thing for someone to have made
up. So, we think he actually said it.
He's delegating his judgment. Why is
Jesus taking all of these divine
prerogatives and giving them to human
beings if he's more than just a human
being himself? But of course, he's not
just a human being qua his position.
He's a very special kind of human being.
Someone who according to the uh the
non-gosspel New Testament sources is
exalted given the name above every other
name. Interesting implication for the
the divine name bearing model. By the
way, what is the best interpretation is
all I basically have to ask of all of
these points. I mean, we got quite
caught caught up in there in the in the
nature of blasphemy and what Jesus could
have been claiming. Again, I'll just
press the point that if you want to
accept that Jesus couldn't have been
accused of blasphemy for anything other
than claiming to be Yahweh and yet all
he really did was quote Daniel 7, then
you have to believe that at the time of
Jesus's trial, it was popular enough
within Jewish thought to expect that the
coming son of man, as prophesied in
Daniel 7, would be Yahweh himself. I
don't see any evidence for that at all.
So for these considerations, I think it
a suspicious reading of the New
Testament to say that Jesus was claiming
identity with Yahweh. All right. Before
we go to the first question, I got one
question for Alex and and I would love
to hear your answer on this. I'm going
throw a monkey wrench in this whole
thing. Um you've brought this up before.
The idea in Eastern Orthodoxy of theosis
or deification, does that solve the
dilemma that you're referring to? uh
theosis the process of humans attaining
likeness to and union with God
participating in the divine energies uh
divine nature and experiencing community
with the holy if we're adding the
Eastern Orthodox position which is
within the realms of orthodoxy as
Protestants would probably call that
glorification right they're giving very
specific language your dilemma is Jesus
is God and then he's given this god-like
authority to his disciples could you
concede potentially that that solves the
dilemma only if that also describes how
Jesus relates to his own father because
of Constantly Jesus is using the word
cathos or cathos. Cathos, which means
just as in the same way as. So sure
maybe this is talking about a kind of
elevation of humans to share in the
likeness of God in in in some other kind
of way, but deification. Yeah,
deification. But then Jesus would have
to see himself in the same way, which is
in so many words what I'm trying to say
Jesus was in fact doing. So yes. Okay,
cool. All right, we're going to go to
questions. Um, so, uh, let's All right.
We have got it. We're gonna get through
this real quick. We got a question from
Avery. All right.
Oh, hold the mic. Okay. All right. For
sure. Uh, what's going on, guys? So,
this is a question for Alex, man. How
you doing, man? Hey. Um, you mentioned
God logic. Yes. Yes, sir. You mentioned,
uh, in Hebrews 1 where, you know, God is
speaking, you know, God uh spoke to our,
you know, you know, uh, through
prophets. Now, he speaks to us through
his son. And you're saying where was
Jesus then? You know back then he should
have been active. And so you know
regarding Hebrews I want just want to
read you this and get your thoughts on
this. Okay it's Hebrews 11 regarding
Moses. It says by faith Moses and I'm
going just skip down to 25 and 26 for
time. Choosing rather to be mistreated
with the people of God than to enjoy the
fleeting pleasures of sin. He considered
the reproach of Christ greater wealth
than the treasures of Egypt, for he was
looking to the reward. So how is it that
Moses can be considering Christ's
disapproval if Christ wasn't around for
him to disapprove?
Yeah, that is a great question. So
Christ there he regarded disgrace for
the sake of Christ as greater value than
the treasures of Egypt because he was
looking ahead to his reward.
Now that's something which I I think
yeah I I think it's a good point. I I
mean of course I can offer a
christoologgical interpretation of this
which sort of says that Christ is
promised as the redeemer of mankind and
we're looking at this in retro where
where's he gone? Oh there you are. We're
looking just dropped it and left. And I
suppose we're we're looking at this in
retrospect and he regarded disgrace for
the sake of Christ. Yeah, I do I do
think that in this instance, Hebrews is
probably presenting Jesus
as I don't know about the angel of
Yahweh, but certainly we're looking at a
high christologology in in Hebrews.
Yeah. So close.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I see what you're
saying.
All right. Let's go to the next question
cuz we want to go. He's so close, guys.
But I I I have no I I for what it's
worth I have no problem saying that
Hebrews has a high christologology. Uh
that that's not that's kind of that's
kind of not an issue to me. But I think
it is interesting to suggest that as a
retort to the idea of the angel of
Yahweh being Jesus. I think that is an
excellent point. Yeah. Yeah. Great job.
All right. Um
uh we got a question for David Wood real
quick. Gentlemen, thank you for a
wonderful debate. Um Dr. would uh
regarding the I am statements of Jesus
in the Gospel of John, the most
palpable, powerful divine statements by
Christ. Why do you believe that they are
omitted from Mark, from Q, from Matthew
and Luke, our four earliest gospels and
then John comes along and these
statements are present in John and
missing from all of our other sources.
Did I bring up I am statements?
Who brought them up?
That's the question. It it it is
fascinating if you walk in and you say,
"All right, I'm going to quote all these
passages in John." They go, "Ah, it's
too late. It's the latest source. You
can't trust that. It's uh clearly made
up later and so on." And so you say,
"Okay, let me just go with the earliest
material. Go Q Mark and Paul." And then
it's what what about John? That's uh
very interesting. So I can't quote John,
but they can quote John. These are these
are uh these are awesome times. Um
uh one I I think the I think the uh I
think the synoptic gospel writers are
focusing on different
theological issues. Um and so in in in
Mark for instance, you have the you have
the announcement you have the
announcement that John the Baptist is
preparing the way for Jesus. But he
actually quotes uh Isaiah that the
messenger is going to prepare the way
for the Lord. And so if you look if you
look at how it unfolds, it's raising all
these questions. Who is this guy who
says he can forgive sins? This guy calls
him this guy says that he's the Lord of
the Sabbath. U you you you do have you
do have an I am statement uh there in
Mark 6:50, but there are p there are
passages where it could just be it could
just be translated as as it is I. which
is why I don't point to these, but they
are they are there and that's the
context where it would make sense um
because this is this is a this is a
really powerful religious moment for
them. So, you could interpret it that
way, but since uh since it's kind of
ambiguous, I don't. But as far as far as
why material is quoted in John that's
not quoted in other gospels, again, I
think they're focusing on different
issues. You look at Mark, it's very
action-based. Jesus went here, did this.
Jesus went here there and did that. Um
and yet you have it um unfolding to who
Jesus is claiming to be. Um he event he
eventually gets to the point where once
his followers grant that he's the
Messiah, then he starts modifying
people's expectations of what the
Messiah is. That's when you have him
saying, "Well, how does David call the
Messiah Lord if he's just the son of
David?" And then you eventually get to
the trial and it's this guy has to die.
But this is just Jesus went here and did
this. it's not focusing a lot on Jesus
teaching. And then you get Matthew, he
takes the same material, but he includes
uh he includes some long sermons and so
on. So, he's including that material. Um
Luke focuses more on parables and so on.
And John just focuses John just focuses
more on personal encounters with Jesus.
That's why you get his interactions with
uh Nicodemus and the woman at the well
and uh Mary and Martha and Lazarus
focusing on personal encounters and some
of the christoologgical claims. But one
of the mistakes people make is saying oh
these and this lots of scholars make
this mistake is John must be late
because of all this this highris high
christologology and christoologgical
statement. It doesn't make any sense
because we know when Paul was writing
and you can't say John is somehow has a
higher christologology than what you
find in Paul. So, we know the we know
the extremely high christologology is
very very early. Um, but yeah, I think I
think the writers are focusing on on
different things. All right, I'm going
try to sneak in two real quick. Here's a
quick one. Hey, Steven Nelson from Cross
Bible. Um, I have a question about
Philippians 2 6-7. Is it about the
Greek? You both argued about it. Yeah.
Uh, you you use different translations
of the Greek word morphi. So, on one
side we have the translation of form and
on the other side we have the
translation of nature. Now nature's is
coming from the NIV who being in the
very nature in very nature God and then
take the NASB for Morphe who as he
already existed in the form of God and
Morpheu and then he takes on the form of
a servant morphidulu. So can you guys
justify why you prefer those specific
translations that you used of the Greek
word Morphe in the Christ hymn in
Philippians 2? Let's start with Alex.
Sure. Um, so I was the context in which
I think I brought that up, unless I'm
misremembering, is James Dunn's
interpretation of the passage. So I
suppose I'm trying to make that passage
make sense in in light of my view. Um,
it could be wrong. It could be the wrong
idea. It could mean existing in the form
of God in the sense of being like an
exalted being. Uh, exalted to the to the
level of God. That might be the case. I
don't exactly have a preference. To me,
the question
of the question of Paul's
christologology is secondary to the
question of Jesus claiming to be God. Of
course, it is interesting why Paul might
have a high christologology, although
that that itself is of course debated.
Um, but I think it's an interesting idea
to explore, but I'm happy for the sake
of argument to just grant that Paul had
a high christology. So, I don't know
which is the best interpretation. I
think you would be a much better person
to to to inform. And in fact, I'd like
to know your opinion. I I spoke to this
this chap earlier and and you sort of
you run a biblical Greek cross
comparison uh website. So I I would love
to know what your interpretation of the
verse is or the word I mean morphe.
Um yeah as yeah that was asked to both
of us I think but uh as far as yeah I
mean the morphe would the most obvious
translation would be like form or or
shape or something like that. What the
NIV writers are doing is saying if
someone's in the form of God, what are
you what are you saying? If I say he was
in the form of God, then this happened.
Um, sounds like you're saying somehow in
nature God. And so that's their
interpret that that's the
interpretation. I think that's good. So
I'm I'm fine. I think that's the
meaning. And therefore the NIV the NIV
frequently translates according to the
meaning and not like a a literal
definition. But if someone's in the form
of God, um I think it makes sense to say
um in nature God. What doesn't make
sense is what Dun does is he takes it as
like this means the image of God and it
it just doesn't make sense with the with
the rest of the passage. Something that
is worth pointing out I suppose is that
the same word morphe is used in the long
ending of Mark where Jesus appears in a
different form to two of them. So if
morphe is supposed to mean sort of
essence as in the morphe of God meaning
like having the same sort of essence as
God if that's what it's supposed to mean
then it's unclear why the writers of the
long ending of Mark would say that he
appeared to two other people in a
different morphe it seems to maybe imply
no that makes perfect sense if I say
someone changes appearance or something
like that then that makes perfect sense
if I say someone is in the form of of
God
what could that possibly mean what what
does it mean to be in the form of God
that's what they're saying what does it
mean to be in the form of God. You have
to be there's got to be
something. There's got to be something
about being a nature God. Yeah.
What else is in the form of God? I can
understand what if I if I could form I
know what it would mean to change into
the form of that guy. Yeah. I don't know
what it would be to change in the form
of God. If Dun's interpretation is
correct, which I don't know if it is,
but I think it's an interesting one to
consider. Then Morphe in that context is
talking about being made in the image of
God. And so to be in the form of God
means to be made in the image of God.
And so to appear someone in a different
form means to look different perhaps. It
seems perfectly consistent. In other
words, I don't think it just makes no
sense because that's before he makes
himself nothing by taking the very
nature of a servant being made into.
Yeah, that's the problem. I think that's
problem with with Dun's interpretation
here. But it's not a problem with the
word which we can discuss that if you
like. As far as the as far as far as the
translation totally fine in the form of
God and then made himself nothing. Uh it
depends on how deep the form goes. But
the the key is that in verse 7, he takes
on the form of a servant. So he starts
out in a divine form and then descends
into taking his human form, which I
think is what David was getting at as
well, right? Yeah. Yeah. Well, thank
you. Thank you. Excellent. I'm going to
sneak this last one in here. Sure. Fine
by me. Appreciate it. So, um, this one's
for Alex primarily. Okay. So in the
Babylonian Talmud Sanhedrin 38b there's
a discussion a rabbitic discussion about
Daniel chapter 7 and they're asking
about the verse I looked till thrones
plural were placed says uh uh one throne
is for him and one throne is for David
this is the statement of Rabbi Aka Rabbi
Yose said to him aka blah blah blah
rather the correct interpretation is
that both thrones are for God as one
throne is for justice and the other is
for mercy so why would the rabbis cuz
You're asking about what did the high
priest interpret the passage to mean.
So, so why would the later rabbis of the
second century or of the late 1st
century have come up with an
interpretation saying the son of man is
God after the advent of Christianity,
right? Okay. So, so the passage says
that there are two, this is from
Sanhedrin, right? Yes. That there are
two thrones, one for justice, one for
mercy. Yes. And this was this is
referring to the the rabbitic uh concept
of hamidot the two uh the two forms of
god. uh justice and mercy. Elohim and
Adonai. Sure. Okay. So, in this
interpretation, which is Jesus and which
is the father? Uh well, I if what I mean
to say is if this is the interpretation
in mind, you need to clarify your point.
Which is the father and which is Jesus?
Justice or mercy? Which is which?
No, no, no. I this is this is a this is
I mean, no, no. I'm I'm simply asking
I'm simply asking cuz cuz you said that
there's there you said it was
implausible to suggest that the high
priest would have interpreted that the
son of man is say what you said at the
beginning first about who who said what
and what what the response was. So Rabbi
Aka said uh one throne is for the holy
one and the other is for David meaning
the messiah and then Rabbi Jose rebukes
him and says no no no both thrones the
ancient of days and the son of man are
for God. So that would be identifying
the son of man as God. I see. And so the
son of man in this instance is mercy and
god is justice. Or is it the other way
around? It's I don't that's all Rabbi
Yay says. But he then says that he then
explains what the two thrones are for.
Right. What does he say the two thrones
are for? He says one one is for one is
for justice. Justice and one is for
mercy. So the two thrones are just the
ancient days and the son of man. The
ancient of days is justice and the son
of man is no. Let me clarify. Let me let
me clarify. Yeah. So the the point the
point is when it talks about when it
talks about the two thrones the two
thrones being brought um that Rabbi Aka
says uh okay one is for God and one's
for the Messiah and someone else resp
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you cannot say that one of these thrones
is for the Messiah. It they both have to
be from they both have to be for God.
They both have to be for God. So they're
interpreting the thrones as both having
to be for God and they sort of describe
it as God's attributes are on these
thrones. The point that's why I don't
know why anybody groaned at the question
I was asking if it's if it's God's
attributes which are on the throne and
this is being discussed this is a later
commentary. The point is when you say
this is a human being that the son that
the the son of man the son of man is a
human being. Rabbi Aka said, "Hey,
that's the Messiah." And other people
said, "Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa. You can't say that because
this is clearly a throne for the divine,
but there's only one God, and therefore
both thrones are for God. And we got to
separate." Maybe I'm still just
misharing this, but after saying after
saying that, the explanation is that the
two thrones, one is for justice, one is
for mercy, which you desri described as
God's attributes. Oh, sorry. I shouldn't
take all my So, so if I have been
brought back up to clarify my question.
I'm so sorry. I've been brought back up
to clarify my question. So, come back,
Alex. What I'm asking is so which figure
is justice and which one is mercy? Was
not is not really uh it doesn't really
it's not really relevant here. I mean,
I'm just saying it's it's rather that
this is showing that rabbis after the
advent of Christianity were recognizing
the son of man in Daniel 7 as an
explicitly divine figure. Because when
Rabbi Aka says, "Oh, it's the Messiah."
He says, "No, no, no. Both figures, the
two distinct figures are God." Oh,
sorry. Yeah. Okay. So, wait. So, after
the advent of Christianity.
So, when are you talking about? You said
after the advent of Christianity when
he's saying that they've had this
argument already and that within the
Jewish Talmud they're arguing about this
throne with two gods. The point is there
are rabbis who interpreted the son of
man as
God. Okay. Okay. Look
I I for for fear of uh
cuz you said it was implausible. That's
what he was responding to. So earlier
you said it was implausible. I
understand that part for for fear of
further misunderstanding and further
groans from the audience. I fear I would
want to read that passage on paper in
front of me which maybe where where's he
gone? There you are. Can you speak to me
after class?
Let's give him a round of applause. Oh
my gosh. All right.
All right, ladies and gentlemen, that
concludes Alex O' Conor versus David
Wood. The Jesus claim to be
God. You guys are getting a standing
applause. That was fun. Yeah, it's
done. You guys can do better than
that. Wow.
Happy birthday,
dear. Happy birthday to you. I did not
tell them to do that. That was
completely unprovoked. Thank you.